ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
[inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAO.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN -- WHEN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA IN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS.
RAY.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH.
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
AS PART OF OUR REMEMBRANCE OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF
NINETEEN FIFTEEN TODAY'S PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR GUEST
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND FATHER
YOUR RE SHOP HI GGN.
OF SAINT JAMES ARMENIAN
APOSTOLIC CHURCH HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
FATHER SUCH AS YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
ALL LOVING GOD.
WE BOW OUR HEADS TO YOU IN
GRATITUDE.
I'M NOT AS FOR YOUR BLESSING
UPON ALL.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE MAN AND WOMAN
OF THIS CHAMBER.
AS EACH OF US FULFILLS OUR
DUTIES OF REPLENISHING THE EARTH
WITH DIVINE LOVE.
WE PLEAD FOR YOUR WISDOM AND
GUIDANCE.
HELP US TO PATIENTLY SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES ENTRUSTED TO US.
AND TO BE ABLE TO INSTILL IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
ALIVE FIELD WITH HOLD.
ENTRUST TOWARDS ONE ANOTHER.
STRENGTHEN US TO HAVE THE
COURAGE. TO ALWAYS DO WHAT IS
RIGHT.
AND TO JUST.
TODAY WE HONOR THE MARTYRS OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
WHOSE LIVES WERE STOLEN ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR YEARS AGO.
BY THE OTTOMAN GOVERNMENT'S.
AGAIN AND AGAIN WE ARE THIS
ROUTE.
OUR HEARTS ARE BROKEN.
BUT WE ARE HOPEFUL.
IN THE FACE OF INJUSTICE AND
DENIAL.
THE TASK OF RAISING AWARENESS
AND EDUCATING HAS FALLEN INTO
OUR OWN HANDS.
SO THAT THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
WOULD NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
GENOCIDES.
THE LAST THE LOST LIVES OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
IN ALL THE GENOCIDES.
CANNOT BE BROUGHT BACK
[inaudible]
BUT HOPEFULLY.
THE WAY WE LIVE OUR LIVES AND
THE JOINT CHOICES WE MAKE.
WILL BE A FRAGMENT.
OF WHAT THEY DREAMS TO SEE.
AS THEY FELL.
UNDER THE SCORCHING HEAT OF THE
DESERT AND ELSEWHERE.
WE PRAY THAT YOU'LL BLESS THE
MEMBERS OF THIS ASSEMBLY.
IN ORDER THAT THEY MAY ACT IN
ACCORDANCE. TO YOUR WILL.
AS THEY PURSUE WHAT IS NOBLE AND
US.
GUIDE AND PROTECT THEM IN THEIR
QUEST TO SERVE HUMANITY.
WITH HUMILITY.
AND GRACE. NINE FOUR OF ROOM ALL
MEN.
THANK YOU FATHER.
THE ARMENIAN GENERAL ATHLETIC
UNION AND SCOUTS KNOWN AS THE
WHOLE MINUTE MEN HAVE BEEN
INVITED TO PRESENT OUR COLORS.
PRESENT OUR FLAGS RATHER FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE THE COLOR GUARD WILL
PLEASE PRESENT THE COLORS
.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS AREA AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MISTER IN HIS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
.
COLOR GUARD PLEASE RETIRED THE
COLORS
.
THE COLOR GUARD MAY.
RETIRED THE COLORS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY APRIL SECOND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN EASY MOMENTO
SEVEN AM THE ABA BRIAN DAHLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORCES FOR
CITING SHE FORTY DAWSON WAS AT
THE DESK CLERK AT THE MOST
READING FOLLOWING REPLACE BONTA
MORNING ROLL CALL.
AGUIAR-CURRY NOW BAUER-KAHAN
JOURNAL CALDERON MOVES AND MR
FLORA SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW SOMETHING
MEMBERS IS ARIAN.
THREE OF US.
FRIEDMAN AND WEBER TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY GUESTS WILL BE AT
THE ROSTRUM FOR THE ASSEMBLY
SUBVERT OBSERVANCE OF ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE REMEMBRANCE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
KALRA AND DAILY TO SPEAK ON THE
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
ENJOYABLE SIXTY TWO A THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT. TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO SET
BILLS PENDING REFERRAL TO ALLOW
THE GEO COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB
TWELVE FORTY TWO ARE ONE FOR
THEIR WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH HEARING.
PENDING WE WERE FOR ALL FROM THE
PRIVACY CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE CRISTINA GARCIA.
PENDING RECEIPT FROM THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE AND TO NOTICE AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY WICKS.
PENDING RECEIPT FROM THE PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR HEARING ON THURSDAY
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
COMMITTEE.
AB ONE THIRTY SIX QUIRK SILVA
FROM HEALTH COMMITTEE TO THE
REVENUE TAXATION COMMITTEE.
AB TWO NINETY SIX COOLEY FROM
THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE TO
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
AB TO ANYONE FRAZIER FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
NINE MAYES FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AB EIGHT NINETY ONE BURKE FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY ADMINISTRATIVE
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE A. B.
NINE THIRTY ONE BORN HARD AFTER
FROM THE ACCOUNTABILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB TEN SIXTY FORMER SUIT YOU
FROM THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO THE
PROCREATION COMMITTEE A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT MCCARTY
FROM APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
THE REVENUE.
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE AB
SIXTEEN FORTY LEVINE FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AND THAT'S IT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO WITHDRAW AB TWO
SEVENTY TWO MURATSUCHI AND A. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE CHAO FROM THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE IN ORDER
THIS BILLS TO SECOND READING.
THEY THE BILLS ARE NO LONGER
FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
A WITHDRAWAL AB EIGHT EIGHTY
OBERNOLTE FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE BILL TO
THE SECOND READING FILE.
I GET WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT REAL SIXTY TWO WAY THE
FALL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB. FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN RUBIO OUT
THERE TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY THREE
HEARING.
MR FLORA FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOUR
ANSWER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS CONSENT ASK
FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA AND NO
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN-HI.
MR FLORA A NO.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION.
IT TAKES.
FORTY ONE CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL.
EYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS FOURTEEN
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER GAS IN
THE CHAMBER.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN ORDER
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER WITH US TODAY MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GUESS INTRODUCTION.
OR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IS A
MEMBER I'M HAPPY HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE FORCE GREATER STUDENTS.
AND PARENTS TEACHERS.
FROM THE ODDS OF BETA ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL FROM OF FREMONT.
S. THANK YOU JEFF BROWN AND JUDY
JUNE EASY FOR ORGANIZING THIS
TRIP WELCOME TO THE STATE
CAPITOL.
AND THAT AND THE FACT.
I DO FLOW TO ADD THAT IT IS
REALLY A GREAT WAY TO LEARN THE
SECOND LANGUAGE.
AND I HOPE WE CAN PROMOTE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS ALL OVER THE
STATE IN THE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
AND THEN -- IN A COUPLE OF YEARS
WHEN I INTRODUCED TO SCHOOL
AGAIN.
IT WILL BE THE ONLY ONE IN
FREMONT THE HOUSE A CHINESE
IMMERSION PROGRAM.
AND PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME AND HOPEFULLY WE WILL
SEE THEM BACK IN TWO YEARS FROM
NOW ON THIS FLOOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR VISITING US
.
AND I BELIEVE MISTER FLOOR -- MR
GRAY AND MR RODRIGUEZ ALL HAVE
GUESTS.
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER MISTER
FLORA I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD TO
INTRODUCE CALIFORNIA HANDLES
ASSOCIATION TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN STAR OF LIFE WERE
SEATED IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
THE STARS OF LIFE HERE FROM
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO HELP
EDUCATE US ON THE WORK THEY DO
IS FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND THE IMPACT THEY HAVE ON
STATE LAWS HAVE ON HEALTH CARE
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM
THANK YOU.
AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ ON THIS
INTRODUCTION.
MEMBERS ALSO RISE -- TO
CONGRATULATE AND THANK THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS A PRIOR AWARD HE OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND WITH -- STORES A
LOT FOR THE RECIPIENT.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE DEDICATION
THE SACRIFICES THAT THESE MEN
AND WOMEN DO TO PROTECT US HERE
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA SO ONCE
AGAIN.
I CONGRATULATE THE TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION STARS A LOCKED WARD
RECIPIENTS FOR THAT FOR THE HARD
WORK AND DEDICATION THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AND FINALLY MR GRAY.
ON YOUR INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE
STARLIGHT AWARD RECIPIENTS FROM
MY DISTRICT.
EACH YEAR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ACCEPTS AWARD
APPLICATIONS FOR PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO HONOR
THOSE WHO.
PERFORMED ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
CALL OF DUTY.
THIS YEAR THE TWENTY FIRST
GESTURES WELL REPRESENTED WITH
FOUR RECIPIENTS FROM MY DISTRICT.
RUSSELL BANKS.
KIMBERLY ISAACSON FROM MERCED
COUNTY AND CHUCK QUITE LOW BRIAN
HANNER MEYER FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY.
WELCOME TO THE STATE CAPITOL
CONGRADULATIONS.
AND MR TANG I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
GROUP THAT'S ARRIVED IN THE
GALLERY.
MR TENURE RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE STUDENTS FROM.
YOU MEAN SCHOOL IN OAKLAND THE
REMAINDER MERCER PROGRAM AND
REALLY HAPPY THAT THEY'RE
VISITING US IN SACRAMENTO THIS
WEEK SO WELCOME TO YOU MAY
.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY REMEMBER ENDS.
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE OF
NINETEEN FIFTEEN MS REED S. ARE
YOU READY TO PROCEED ON FILE
ITEM.
FIFTY NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY NINE EIGHT J. R..
SIXTEEN THE CAR COREY.
JOINT RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER THREE OF US ANOTHER'S
RELATIVE TO THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISERY OF US MYSTERY OF US YOU
MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- IT'S AN HONOR TO
PRESENT AJ ARE SIXTEEN THAT
DESIGNATES APRIL TWENTY FOURTH
TWENTY NINETEEN AS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE OF NINETEEN FIFTEEN IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE BEGINNING
ON APRIL TWENTY FOURTH NINETEEN
FIFTEEN IN AN EFFORT TO RADIC
KATE.
THE ARMENIAN NATION THE YOUNG
TURKS GOVERNMENT OF THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE SYSTEMATICALLY
SLAUGHTERED ARMENIAN MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN.
THE GENOCIDE CONTINUED FROM.
NINETEEN TWENTY TO NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE THIS RESOLUTION
PAYS HOMAGE TO THE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION AMER ARMENIANS THAT
WERE KILLED.
DURING THIS HORRIFIC PERIOD OF
TIME.
MEMBERS WHEN WE THINK OF ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE IT'S
HARD TO CAPTURE WITH THAT TRULY
MEANS.
PRIOR TO THE GENOCIDE THERE WERE
TWO MILLION ARMENIANS LIVING IN
THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE BUT WITHIN A
SHORT TIME THREE QUARTERS OF AN
ACCIDENT.
ANCIENT I'M SORRY ANCIENT
CIVILIZATION PERISHED AND AN
ENTIRE NATION WAS NEARLY
OBLITERATED.
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
MILLIONS OF STORIES NEVER TOLD?
FUTURE GENERATIONS NEVER BORING
AND MILLIONS OF SHATTERED
FAMILIES AND DREAMS.
AS THE HOME OF THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF ARMENIAN AMERICANS
IN THE UNITED STATES CALIFORNIA
RECOGNIZES THE MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY HAS MADE THROUGH THEIR
LEADERSHIP IN GOVERNMENT
AGRICULTURE ACADEMIA BUSINESS
AND THE ARTS.
HOWEVER IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
SIMPLY ACKNOWLEDGE THESE
CONTRIBUTIONS WE HAVE THE MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY. TO CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS TO NOW TO NOT
ALLOW THE ATROCITIES AND THE
VIOLATIONS OF HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMITTED BY THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT AGAINST ARMENIANS.
AND OTHER CHRISTIANS TO BE
FORGOTTEN THIS IS WHY TODAY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND ASKED FOR
THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER EVANS MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF
HR.
SIXTEEN OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
THE WORLD WITNESSED THE
SLAUGHTER OF ONE AND A HALF
MILLION ARMENIAN MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHO WERE EXILED FROM
THE HISTORIC HOMELAND.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
AMERICA'S LARGEST ARMENIAN
AMERICAN DIASPORA.
AND MOST OF THEM HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO ARE SURVIVORS AND
HAVE EXPERIENCED THE EVIL OF
GENOCIDE FIRST HAND.
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING SUPPORTING IN MANY
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES AND SEEKING
JUSTICE FOR THIS CRIME AS IT HAS
GONE ON RECOGNIZE FOR FAR TOO
LONG.
AS WE CONTINUE TO SEEK JUSTICE
FOR THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WE
ALSO CELEBRATE THE SURVIVAL OF A
PEOPLE WHO HAVE CONTRIBUTED SO
MUCH TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS ARTS AND
CULTURE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I AM PROUD
OF OUR STATE AND OUR LEGISLATURE
FOR TAKING IMPORTANT STEPS TO
EDUCATE OUR CITIZENS ABOUT HUMAN
RIGHTS AND GENOCIDE.
IN HOPES TO RAISE A GENERATION
OF LEADERS THAT WILL ALWAYS
CHOOSE LOVE OVER HATE.
AND TOLERANCE OVER
DISCRIMINATION.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AJ ARE.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
AGA ARE.
SIXTEEN WHICH DESIGNATES APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS THE HUNDRED AND
FOURTH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
THE MASSACRE TOOK PLACE FROM.
NINETEEN FIFTEEN TO NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE AND IT BRINGS ME
GREAT SADNESS.
AS I THINK ABOUT THE MILLIONS OF
INNOCENT MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES FROM MASS
BURNINGS FORCE DROWNINGS DEATH
MARCHES AND POISONING?
BRAVE MEN SOUGHT OUT TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES BUT REMAIN
HELPLESS.
WHILE VULNERABLE WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WERE EXILED OR EXECUTED
AS THEIR IDENTITY SELF WORTH.
AND CULTURE WERE SLOWLY BEING
PLUCKED FROM CIVILIZATION.
TODAY CALIFORNIA IS THE HOME TO
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
ARMENIANS FOUR THOUSAND OF WHICH
RESIDE IN MY DISTRICT.
AND CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY
THROUGH LITERATURE CULTURE.
AND VISUAL ARTS.
THE SUFFERING THAT ARMENIAN
POPULATION AND THIRD MEANS
SOMETHING TO ME NOT BECAUSE IT
ILLUSTRATES THE INFRINGEMENT.
OF HUMAN RIGHTSBUT BECAUSE IT
IS A REMINDER OF THEIR COURAGE
AND STRUGGLE TO SURVIVE. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THERE WAS HOLDEN THIS GABRIEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF AJ ARE.
SIXTEEN TODAY WE REMEMBER THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE IN HONOR THOSE
WHOSE LIVES WERE BRUTALLY CUT
SHORT DURING THE FIRST GENOCIDE
OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
WE STAND WITH THOSE WHO LOST
LOVED ONES AND THOSE WHO CAME TO
AMERICA TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
DESPITE THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT'S
EFFORT TO DENY HISTORY WE WILL
NOT FORGET.
WE WILL NOT FORGET THE BRUTALITY
THE DISPLACEMENT AND THE MURDER
OF MORE THAN ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION ARMENIANS.
WE WILL NOT FORGET BECAUSE
DENIAL OF HISTORICAL FACT DENIES
JUSTICE COMPOUNDS INJURY.
UNDERMINES HEALING PREVENTS
CLOSURE AND ENCOURAGES THOSE WHO
SEE GENOCIDE AS LEGITIMATE.
INDEED THERE IS NO BETTER
EXAMPLE THAN THE WORDS OF ADOLF
HITLER WHO IN THE YEARS PRIOR TO
THE HOLOCAUST FAMOUSLY ASK.
WHO AFTER ALL SPEAKS TODAY OF
THE I NEED ANNIHILATION OF THE
ARMENIANS?
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE MUST
SPEAK OF THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
WE MUST REMEMBER HISTORY AS IT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED AND CONDEMN
HATE IN ALL OF ITS FORMS.
IN RECENT WEEKS THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY AND MY DISTRICT IN THE
WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY HAS
BEEN TARGETED BY HATE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A MATTER OF
HISTORY. TO ARMENIAN SCHOOLS IN
THE WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
WERE VANDALIZED WITH TURKISH
FLAGS.
THE EQUIVALENT OF HANGING ****
FLAGS AT A SYNAGOGUE FOR A
JEWISH SCHOOL.
INCIDENTS LIKE THESE REMIND US
THAT WE MUST REMAIN CONSTANTLY
VIGILANT.
ONLY BY BEING HONEST ABOUT THE
HORRORS OF THE PAST CAN WE HOPE
TO PREVENT FUTURE ACTS OF
GENOCIDE.
IN THAT SPIRIT AND ON BEHALF OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AJ ARE.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU RICH GABRIEL
DR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AJ ARE SIXTEEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
WE APPLAUD THE EFFORTS OF THE
ARMENIANS FOR THEIR PURSUIT OF
TRUTH AND JUSTICE FOR THE
ARMENIAN DURING THEIR MEDIANS A
GENOCIDE.
AND THE EXPERIENCE OF ARMENIANS
UNDER THE OTTOMAN EMPIRE IS NOT
MUCH DIFFERENT FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF AFRICAN SLAVES OR
NATIVE AMERICANS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS REALLY QUITE INTERESTING
THAT WE ARE HERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS THE GENOCIDE.
AND ONCE AGAIN COMMITTING
OURSELVES TO NEVER LETTING THIS
HAPPEN AGAIN.
WE KNOW SO MANY WHO HAVE
SUFFERED THIS FORM OF GENOCIDE.
THIS ATTACK ON A INDIVIDUALS
THEIR IDENTITY AND THEIR CULTURE
IN THIS NATION.
THE OTHER DAY I WAS READING AN
ARTICLE IN THE UNION TRIBUNE AS
WE WERE CELEBRATING.
A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY OR FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS I GUESS IT IS FOR
THE ECONOMY AYE INDIANS AND
THEIR CONTACT WITH AMERICANS --
WHO CAME HERE AND IT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE THEY TALKED
ABOUT THIS WHOLE IDEA THAT THE
THOUGHT WAS THAT THEY WOULD JUST
SIMPLY X. -- EXTERMINATE THE
COMEY AYE INDIANS.
AND THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO DO
THAT BUT THEY HAD BASICALLY
REDUCE THEIR NUMBERS DOWN TO
VERY SMALL NUMBERS.
AND PUT THEM INTO PLACES THAT WE
NOW CALL RESERVATIONS IN AREAS
THAT ARE ALMOST DESOLATE WITH
REGARDS THE ABILITY TO GROW
CROPS.
AND THE THOUGHT WAS A WILL JUST
EXTERMINATE THEM AND WE'LL JUST
MOVE ON BECAUSE THEY WERE
OBVIOUSLY NOT USEFUL TO THEM
ANYMORE ONCE THEY HAD NURTURED
THEM BACK TO HEALTH.
BECAUSE THOSE WHO WAS THE
SPANIARD TO CAME HERE WERE ILL
WHEN THEY ARRIVED IN THIS
COUNTRY IN THIS COUNTRY AND SO
THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD
EXTERMINATE THE INDIANS A CALL
ME I BUT THERE WAS SOMETHING
MUCH MORE POWERFUL IN THEM THE
COSTUME TO SURVIVE AND TO LIVE.
WE KNOW OF THE MILLIONS WHO DIED
IN THE MIDDLE PASSAGE COMING
FROM AFRICA TO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT OFTENTIMES OVER 50% OF THE
CARGO WAS THROWN OVERBOARD OF
PEOPLE COMMITTED SORT OUT
SUICIDE IT DIDN'T SURVIVE THE
MIDDLE PASSAGE TO COME HERE.
AND AFTER THAT STILL THE KIND OF
DEGRADATION THAT OCCUR TO TAKE
AWAY THEIR IDENTITY THE TAKE
AWAY THE SENSE OF PURPOSE AND
FOCUS AND SO WE'VE SEEN THIS
COUNTRY BASICALLY PARTICIPATE IN
THIS WHOLE ISSUE.
OF GENOCIDE IN VARIOUS WAYS AND
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS
AROUND THE WORLD WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
DEVASTATING EXPERIENCE.
A LASTING EXPERIENCE THAT NOT
ONLY OF IMPACTS THE FOLKS AT
THAT MOMENT BUT FOR GENERATIONS
AND GENERATIONS TO COME.
IT IS SO IMPERATIVE THAT WE TALK
ABOUT OUR HISTORY IT IS STRONG
THIS FORM SO THE WE TALK ABOUT
THE COURAGE OF THOSE WHO
SURVIVED WHO WERE DETERMINED TO
MAINTAIN THEIR SENSE OF HUMANITY.
AND NOT BE VICIOUS IN THE
PROCESS BUT ALSO TO MAINTAIN
THEIR CULTURE AND TO ACTUALLY
GROW AND DEVELOP FROM WHAT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED.
IT IS -- INTERESTING AS WE STAND
HERE TODAY THAT WE ARE STILL
TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
AND WE ARE FACED WITH SO MANY
HATE CRIMES AND SO MANY THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING THAT WE HAVE
A TENDENCY TO IGNORE THE TAPPED
ON INDIVIDUALS.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IN MY
FAMILY THE BURNING OF THE OF THE
CHURCH IN IN PARIS AND SOMEONE
SAID TO ME BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
THREE BLACK CHURCHES THAT WERE
BURNED IN THE UNITED STATES
DOING ONE WEEKEND.
I MEAN THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO CONFRONT THAT ARE HERE
WITH US AT THIS MOMENT.
AND IF WE DON'T THEN WE ARE NO
BETTER THAN THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE IN THE
GENOCIDE THEMSELVES BECAUSE WERE
TURNING OUT I AWAY FROM THE
SMALL THINGS BUT THEY'RE REALLY
VERY LARGE THINGS AND VERY
SYMPTOMATIC OF A NATION.
THAT REFUSES TO DEAL WITH ITS
HISTORY.
AND ITS PRESENT AND THEREFORE
OBVIOUSLY WILL HAVE CONTINUED TO
DAMAGE THE FUTURE.
I'VE SAID ON THIS FOR MANY MANY
TIMES AND WE HAVE TO BE VIGILANT
WE MUST CONTINUE TO WATCH ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT HAVE A
TENDENCY TO DESTROY US.
AND OUR HUMANITY AND OUR SENSE
OF DEMOCRACY IN FAIRNESS AND
pTHAT HATRED AND INCLUSION IN
THIS NATION IS LIKE A RARE
FLOWER THAT HAS TO BE CONSTANTLY
REMEMBERED AND NURTURED AND
CARED.
FOR BUT HATRED IS A WEEK.
DISCRIMINATION IS A WEEK AND A
GROWS BEST IN THE COLLECT AND WE
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL THAT WE'RE
NOT NEGLECTING WHAT WE SEE THAT
WE ROOTED OUT AND WE CONTINUE TO
GROW THAT WHICH IS WONDERFUL.
I THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR
THIS RESOLUTION AND THE BLACK
CAUCUS STRONGLY SUPPORTS AG ARE
SIXTEEN AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL
VOTE FOR IT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE.
AS I HAVE.
ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS TO SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION -- BECAUSE I
BELIEVE AS I'VE SAID BEFORE THAT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST
THAT WE CONTINUE TO CALL IT WHAT
IT IS?
THAT WE CALL THIS THE GENOCIDE.
THAT WE THAT WE TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE ARMENIAN PEOPLE
AND THAT WE REMEMBER.
THESE THINGS ANNA AND I THINK AS
AS HAS BEEN SPOKEN ON THIS FOR A
LITTLE BIT THIS MORNING IS.
IS THAT WE LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING
ON AROUND THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
OVER THE OVER THE WEEKEND.
ON SUNDAY MORNING -- CELEBRATING
EASTER WITH MY FAMILY AT OUR
CHURCH AND GETTING THE NEWS OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN SRI LANKA.
WHERE THREE HUNDRED OVER THREE
HUNDRED OTHER CHRISTIANS WERE?
MURDERED AS THEY WORST.
PRACTICING THEIR FAITH JUST LIKE.
ME AND MY FAMILY WERE.
THAT MORNING AS WE LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN CHARLESTON
[inaudible]
IN PITTSBURGH.
IN NEW ZEALAND.
AND ALL THESE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN.
RIGHT HERE IN THE PRESENT
[inaudible]
AGE.
IN OUR PRESENT ERA.
WHERE ARE FOR WHATEVER REASON
PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN TO A POINT
WHERE THIS?
THE WORDS EVEN THE WORDS THAT
PEOPLE ARE USING TO DE HUMANIZE
WHERE YOU CAN DE HUMANIZE
SOMEONE AS THE ENEMY.
WE START TO EVEN TALK ABOUT
OURSELVES EVEN AS AMERICANS
TALKING ABOUT THE OTHER SIDE AS
AN ENEMY.
RATHER THAN SOMEONE THAT MAY WE
JUST HAVE A DISAGREEMENT WITH.
AND SO I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
WE REALLY NEED THIS TO START
THINKING ABOUT AS AS LEADERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY -- AS PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO CREATE A BETTER
WORLD FOR OUR CHILDREN -- IS
THAT.
YEAH WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW
HOW WE START TALKING ABOUT EACH
OTHER AND HOW.
WE START BUILDING UP EACH OTHER --
AND THAT WE DON'T WE STOP THIS
YOU KNOW BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
EASY TO GO DOWN A PATH.
AND WE SEEN IT THROUGHOUT
HISTORY IS REALLY EASY TO GO
DOWN A PATH WHERE YOU BEGIN TO
DE HUMANIZE A GROUP.
AND IT GETS TO A POINT WHERE
WE'VE WHERE YOU'VE SEEN THE
ATROCITIES THAT HAVE OCCURRED.
AND WE NEED TO CALL OUT EVIL
WHEREVER IT EXISTS.
WHEN WE SEE THAT EVIL WHEN WE
SEE THE STARTING IS IN THE IN
THE CALLS?
IT'S IT'S NOT ALL THAT SUBTLE.
WE HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE CALLING
FOR THE DEATHS OF CERTAIN GROUPS.
THIS CANNOT BE ALLOWED WE CAN'T
HAVE THIS KIND OF DIALOGUE WE
CAN ALLOW OUR DIALOGUE TO
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TODAY THAT WE THAT
WE REMEMBER.
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WHAT LED
UP TO IT.
HOW IT GOT TO THAT POINT?
HOW EVEN TODAY?
THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT DENIES.
WHAT IT IS DONE?
AND HOW IT NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT
IN THE LIGHT JUST LIKE SO MANY
OTHER THINGS NEED TO BE BROUGHT
TO LIGHT.
AND THEN WE NEED TO LOOK BACK AT
OURSELVES AND LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
AND SAY HEY HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE A DIALOGUE.
WE CAN DISAGREE ON THINGS WE CAN
HAVE DIFFERENCES OF OPINION
DIFFERENT [inaudible]
RELIGIONS -- BUT WE NEED TO ALSO
AT THE TIME AT THE SAME TIME
LEARN TO LIVE WITH EACH OTHER.
AND HAVE A RESPECTFUL AND A
CIVIL DIALOGUE AND I WORRY ABOUT
THAT.
AS IT CONTINUES TO DENIGRATE.
NOW IN OUR COUNTRY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
THAT WE TRY TO LIFT THAT BACK UP.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE OUR
NATION HAS BEEN A BEACON OF
LIGHT.
AS BEING THAT.
THAT NATION THAT CAN LIFT UP THE
DIALOGUE THAT CAN LIFT UP. TO
THE HIGHEST IDEALS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
AND SO I RISE WITH MY MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION AND TO SUPPORT.
THAT KIND OF HIGHER DIALOGUE
THAT KIND OF HIGHER SPIRIT
[inaudible]
THAT WE IN THIS NATION WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAVE THANK YOU.
THEY GIVE US GALLAGHER.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF
FIRST AND FOREMOST I LIKE.
TO OF COMMAND AND OF SAY HOW
MUCH HOW APPRECIATIVE I AM OF OF
MY COLLEAGUE -- REPRESENTS SUN
VALLEY TO BRING THIS A MEASURE
FORWARD.
SHE UNDERSTANDS WELL THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE SHE REPRESENTS MANY
ARMENIAN AMERICANS -- SO I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF AG ARE -- SIXTEEN
I ALSO WANT TO JUST.
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SPOKEN AS
THE RESIDENT ARMENIAN AMERICAN
CALIFORNIAN -- WHO HAS THE HONOR
OF REPRESENTING -- A VOICE THAT
HAS UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
GEOPOLITICS AND HISTORICAL
RESOURCE FIGHTS BEEN UNDER HEARD
AND NOT RECEIVED IT'S DUE
RECOGNITION.
UP.
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR RESOUNDING
SUPPORT AND FOR ALWAYS.
KEEPING THIS VOICE HEARD -- I
ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHULA
VISTA WHO NOT ONLY EVERY YEAR
GIVES AN IMPASSIONED SPEECH.
BUT ALSO THE REFERENCES THAT SHE
HAS MADE -- I OFTEN WONDER ABOUT
THE EXPERIENCE OF ARMENIANS
VERSUS AFRICAN AMERICAN SLAVES --
WHILE BOTH ARE TRAGIC.
I SOMETIMES FEEL.
AS ARMENIANS WE WERE THERE WAS
AN EFFORT TO ERADICATE.
BUT THOSE OF US WHO SURVIVED
STILL NO WHERE OUR LANDS ARE.
STILL NO WHERE WE COME FROM
[inaudible]
STILL NO.
AS YOU WILL SEE THERE IS A BOOK
ON ALL OF YOUR DESKS.
THERE'S FIGHTS OVER SEND
SPENDING OVER CENTURIES OF WHAT
PAGES OF WHAT MANUSCRIPTS WERE
STOLEN.
AND FOR WHAT.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IT WAS SOLD
TO WITH THIS MUSEUM WHERE THAT
MUSEUM AND NOW THEY'RE ALL BEING
WEEK.
RECOLLECTED AND BEING PUT INTO
BACK INTO ONE ONE PLACE.
SO THERE IS A CON CONTINUATION.
TO THE HISTORY.
THROUGH THE FACT THAT WE
SURVIVED.
AND WE WERE ABLE.
TO LAKE CLAIM AND CONTINUE TO
FIGHT AND PURSUE THAT CLAIM.
WHEN I TALK TO MY AFRICAN
AMERICAN FRIENDS AND THIS IS
GOING BACK TO THE TIME WHEN I
WAS A TEENAGER?
AND TRY TAKES ASK WILL DO YOU
KNOW WHERE YOUR FAMILY CAME FROM
INITIALLY.
AND TO HAVE THAT FAMILIAR OLD.
BOND NOT BEING ABLE TO BE
STRETCHED BEYOND JUST YOUR
GRANDPARENTS GENERATION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE NEVER
FELT.
I'VE NEVER KNOWN HOW HARD THAT
IS. TO HAVE A TO HAVE
[inaudible]
A LINE.
COMPLETELY BROKEN AND NOT EVEN
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE FROM.
AND WHEN WE SWEEP ISSUES LIKE
THIS UNDER THE CARPET.
WHICH IS HAPPENING BECAUSE OF A
COUPLE OF THINGS COLLEAGUES
LET'S BE HONEST.
IS SHE POLITICS ITS OIL.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS. TO THIS DAY.
THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
WILL [inaudible]
DEMOLISH.
OR BREAK A PART.
TAKE DOWN CROSSES.
DESTROY ANY TYPE OF CULTURAL
ARTIFACTS ON ITS LAND.
AND THE REPUBLIC OF AZERBAIJAN
AND ITS OWN FOOTAGE.
IT'S YOU CAN SEE IT ON YOU. TO
TO THIS DAY.
THAT DESTRUCTION HAPPENS IN
ORDER TO REVISE HISTORY TO SAY
THAT THIS ANGEL PEOPLE ANCIENT
PEOPLE WHO LIVED THERE FOR FIVE
THOUSAND YEARS.
REALLY WAS NOT THERE IT'S ALL.
FICTION.
THIS IS HAPPENING.
IN OUR LIFETIMES.
THIS IS HAPPENING WHILE WE HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
CAPABILITY TO SEE WHAT'S WHAT
AND WHERE EVERYTHING IS.
AND IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW SO
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE.
WHAT THE MONTH OF APRIL TO ME
FEELS LIKE BECAUSE IT'S THIS
TREMENDOUS WEIGHT?
EVERY TIME MARCH ENDS AND APRIL
BEGINS.
AND IRONICALLY APRIL IS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE MONTH OF REBIRTH.
IT SUPPORT WE JUST CELEBRATED
NOR IS LESS THAN A MONTH AGO.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE THE TIME
THAT.
LIFE IS BLOOMING AND
REGENERATING [inaudible]
AND YET. TWO WEEKS AGO WE
RECOGNIZE THE CAMBODIAN
[inaudible]
GENOCIDE.
NEXT WEEK WE'RE GONNA BE
RECOGNIZING THE JEWISH HOLOCAUST.
AT SOME POINT WE WILL BE ALSO.
MAKING SURE EVEN THOUGH IT'S IN
SPOKEN WORDS IN ALL OF OUR ALL
OF OUR COMMENTS THE RWANDAN
GENOCIDE WAS ALSO IN APRIL.
ALONG WITH THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
IT.
EVERYONE OF THEM HAVE HAPPENED
IN A DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
IN ONE CASE. ONE WAS KILLED ON
THEIR OWN LAND IN ANOTHER CASE.
ONE MAD MEN WENT AROUND ALL THE
OTHER COUNTRIES AND MADE SURE
ALL THE DIE ASPIRIN COMMUNITIES
WERE KILLED IN ANOTHER.
THE ONLY REGION KILLED ITS OWN
PEOPLE IN ANOTHER AREA TWO
TRIBES THAT HAVE BEEN LIVING
TOGETHER FOR CENTURIES.
WE'RE COMMITTING THE ATROCIOUS
HORRIFIC ACTIVITIES WITH AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER -- AND UNFORTUNATELY
HERE ON OUR OWN LAND.
WE STILL YET.
TO A DRESS APPROPRIATELY WHAT IS
HAPPENED. TO THE INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES OF THE UNITED STATES.
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WAS ESTABLISHED
[inaudible]
SO -- I I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
STANDING.
UP I I JUST WANT TO MAKE.
THERE ARE TWO PROFOUND COMMENTS
THE STATEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE OVER TIME THAT I THINK
SPEAK VERY WELL TO THIS ISSUE.
ONE IS THAT I I CAN'T HELP BUT
TO REMEMBER THE POINT WORDS OF
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING WHEN
YOU SO ACCURATELY STATED IN THE
END.
WE WILL REMEMBER NOT THE WORDS
OF OUR ENEMIES BUT THE SILENCE
OF OUR FRIENDS.
AND THAT AN INJUSTICE IN ONE
PLACE IS AN INJUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
RAISING THE SECOND.
ONE BUT THE OTHER ONE FROM
PHILOSOPHER AND WRITER MILAN
KUNDERA.
THE STRUGGLE OF MAN AGAINST
POWER IS THE STRUGGLE OF MEMORY
AGAINST FORGETTING.
ALL OF US HERE IN THIS CHAMBERS
KNOW WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
BECAUSE OF OUR POSITIONS WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR EXPOSURE.
BUT MANY OF OUR RESIDENTS.
LIVING IN THE FIFTY LARGEST
ECONOMY OF THE WORLD THAT HAS
THE BENEFITS AND THE RICHES.
OF INFORMATION AT THEIR
FINGERTIPS.
STILL DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THESE
ISSUES.
AND THE LONGER THEY GO ON NOT
KNOWING.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATELY WHAT ALLOWS.
HORRIFIC ACTIVITIES TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT THEY DID.
IF WE DON'T TAKE STEPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE PAID THE PRICE.
FOR THE ACTIVITIES THAT THEY
COMMITTED THE HORRORS THAT THEY
COMMITTED.
IN THIS CASE WHEN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ENCINO SPOKE ABOUT THE
FLAGS BEING PUT UP.
MANY OF US EVEN HERE WOULD SAY.
WHY DOES A FLAG IGNITE SUCH
HORRIFIC MEMORIES [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
WHEN HITLER TOOK OVER GERMANY HE
CHANGED THE FLAG?
AND PUT THE SWASTIKA ON THE FLAG.
WHEN HITLER FELL?
THE FLAG WENT AWAY.
SYMBOLIZING THAT THE REGIME.
IS GONE.
WE WILL NEVER TRY TO BRING THAT
BACK AGAIN.
THE TURKISH REPUBLICS FLAG.
IS STILL THE SAME.
FROM PHOTOS YOU CAN EVEN LOOK AT
WHEN THEY WOULD MASS HANG.
COMMUNITY LEADERS IN TOWNS AND
CITIES IN ARMENIA.
HISTORIC LANDS OF ARMENIA.
AND YET THE CLAIM THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS CHANGED THE
SYMBOLS HAVE CHANGED.
AND THAT THEY ARE REFORMED AND
THAT WAS IN THE PAST.
IF WE LET THE PAST CONTINUE TO
NOT BE RESOLVED.
AND TO CONTINUE TO HAUNT --
IT'LL ONLY IMPACT THIS GOING
INTO THE FUTURE AND WE WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES IN FACT.
THE CHALLENGES WILL BECOME WORSE
OR AND WERE SIR OVER THE YEARS
SO WITH THAT I SUPPORT AG ARE
SIXTEEN THANK YOU FOR THE CALL
MY COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING IT.
AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
OF THE RESOLUTION IS REVERSE YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE MEMBERS
THAT SET UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE TO THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPENED FOR CO
AUTHORS. THREE THIS IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS MEMBERS CORPORAL
OPENING ROLE.
AS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON H. A R. SIXTEEN THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ADDED ON THE RESOLUTION.
AND WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE H. A R. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU VOTE I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO THAT RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
IS ADOPTED.
AND MR NECESSARY AND I'M GOING
TO RECOGNIZE YOU FROM MY DESK IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND COLLEAGUES I'M PROUD TO
INTRODUCE CONSUL GENERAL OF LOS
ANGELES AMBASSADOR DR ARMIN BY
POOR TN.
OF MR BY BRIDGE AND IS NO
STRANGER TO CALIFORNIA OR TO LOS
ANGELES HE WAS THE FOUNDING --
CONSUL GENERAL OF THE LOS
ANGELES CONSULAR OFFICE -- IN --
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR AND TWENTY
FIVE YEARS LATER HE IS HERE
REPRESENTING -- THIS COMMUNITY
AND THIS STATE AGAIN IN HIS
MISSION -- I I IT GIVES ME GREAT --
PRIVILEGE AND HONOR TO RECOGNIZE
HIM AND INVITE HIM. TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE FLOOR -- WITH THAT
PLEASE RECOGNIZE -- AMBASSADOR
ARMINE BY BURKE CHEN THANK YOU
MR NECESSARY IN YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE FOR AN ADDITIONAL
GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND TIME IN YOUR ATTENTION --
I'M PROUD TO INTRODUCE HAD IN
OUR SIX BILLION WALKING POP --
HAVE IN OUR IS A PROFESSOR AT U.
S. AT UC DAVIS.
THAT SPECIAL AND SPECIALIZES IN
THE HISTORY OF ART AND
ARCHITECTURE IN THE MIDDLE EAST
INCLUDING ARCHITECTURAL
PRESERVATION MUSEUMS AND
CULTURAL HERITAGE SHE IS ALSO AN
AWARD WINNING AUTHOR.
SHE WROTE THE MISSING PAGES THE
MODERN LIFE OF A MEDIEVAL
MANUSCRIPTS FROM GENOCIDE TO
JUSTICE WHICH ALL OF YOU HAVE
RECEIVED A COPY COPY OF ON YOUR
DESKS.
HER BOOK THE IMAGE OF AN OTTOMAN
CITY WAS AWARDED THE SPIRO COST
OFF.
BOOK PRICE FROM THE SOCIETY OF
ARCHITECTURAL HISTORIANS SHE IS
ALSO RECEIVED THE BEST ARTICLE
AWARD FROM THE SYRIAN STUDIES
ASSOCIATION AND THE ALL MORE
LUTFI BARK ON ARTICLE PRICE FROM
THE OTTOMAN AND TRICKY STUDIES
ASSOCIATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THE
VERY.
OF EXTINGUISHED A THE THE VERY --
HONORABLE GET OUR WONDERFUL
AUTHOR HAS YOU KNOW IS THAT THE
ON WALKING PAUL WHY BELIEVE IS
SITTING.
IN THE GALLERY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR IS ARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND AS WE ARE REMEMBER THIS
SUMMER PERIOD IN HISTORY IT IS
ALSO IMPERATIVE TO CELEBRATE THE
SUCCESS AND LONGEVITY OF AN ART
OF THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY. FOR
THAT REASON THE CALIFORNIA
ARMENIAN LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IS
PROUD TO ANNUALLY SPONSORS
SCHOLARSHIP CONTEST FOR THE
COMMEMORATION OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
THIS YEAR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WERE INVITED TO WRITE AN ESSAY
ASKING THEM TO NOMINATE AN
ARMENIAN AMERICAN THAT COULD BE
FEATURED IN AN EXHIBIT.
IN A STILL TO BE CONSTRUCTED
ARMENIAN AMERICAN NATIONAL
MUSEUM WITH THE MUSEUM TO BE
LOCATED IN GLENDALE CALIFORNIA --
IN IN ASSEMBLY WOMAN OF LAURA
FRIEDMAN IS DISTRICT.
STUDENTS COULD ALSO SUBMIT A
VISUAL ARTS PIECE ON THE THEME
OF HUMAN TO HUMAN INTERACTION
AND HOW WE CAN INCREASE GREATER
AWARENESS OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
THE FIRST PLACE WINNERS OF EACH
CONTEST EARNED A MONETARY
CONTRIBUTION -- AND IT IS --
WITH CLICK GREAT PLEASURE TO IN
INTRODUCE -- THE TWO OF FIRST
PLACE WINNERS -- IN FIRST PLACE
FOR THE ESSAY CONTEST THAT LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE JONATHAN ALPERT.
A SOPHOMORE AT HILLTOP HIGH
SCHOOL IN CHULA VISTA JONATHAN
WROTE ABOUT HIS GREAT
GRANDMOTHER ESTHER MCGRADY CHEN.
ESTHER ESCAPED THE HORRORS OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
I THREW A DARING ESCAPE TO
RUSSIA AND WAS ABLE TO DOCUMENT
HER STORY IN HER BOOK ENTITLED
FROM TURKISH TOILETS
CONGRATULATIONS JONATHAN.
I BELIEVE IN SITTING UP THERE
RIGHT BEHIND.
AND MISTER IS THERE IN YOUR
RECORD.
NOW IN FIRST PLACE FOR THE
VISUAL ARTS CONTEST I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE JOE AND WU.
A FRESHMAN AT PIEDMONT HILLS
HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN JOSE JOANNE'S
PIECE TITLED HELPING HANDS SHOWS
A YOUNG GIRL CARRYING HER LITTLE
BROTHER AWAY FROM FIRES.
THAT WERE COMMON DURING THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
CONGRATULATIONS ON WINNING FIRST
PLACE JOANNE.
ALSO BEHIND ME IN THE GALLERY
THANK YOU BOTH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
MISTER NAZARIAN IN THE API
CAUCUS WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS SOLEMN
REMEMBRANCE.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
A MEMBERS PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME
AMBER ROSE A BAKERSFIELD AND HER
FRIEND.
SKI WE'RE SITTING IN THE GALLERY
TODAY AMBER AND ERIN ARE HERE TO
COMMEMORATE APRIL ASKING GENERAL
DIAPHRAGMATIC HERNIA AWARENESS
MONTH OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE C.
H..
A CONJUNCTION WITH ACR FIFTY
FIVE WHICH IS NOW IN THE SENATE.
THIS IS THESE ARE C. H. IS KNOWN
AS A RARE BIRD THE FACT THAT
AFFECTS THE DIAPHRAGM SEPARATING
THE CHESS ORGANS FROM THE DOMINO
ORGANS.
A WHOLE THE DIAPHRAGM ALLOWS A
DOMINO ORGANS TO PUSH THROUGH A
CROWD THE LUNGS AND HEART
CAUSING ABNORMAL AN OFTEN FATAL
DEVELOPMENT. ONE IN TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CHILDREN BORN ARE
DIAGNOSED WITH C. H. -- EVENTS
WITH C. H. HAVE LITTLE TO NO
LONG PUNCHEON DEPENDING ON THE
SEVERITY OF THE OF THE DEFECT
AND ARE UNABLE TO BREATHE ON
THEIR OWN.
NEWBORNS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
TAKE ENOUGH OXYGEN AND NINE OF
BLOOD FLOWS TO THE LUNGS.
MORE THAN HALF OF INFANTS
DIAGNOSED WITH SEVERE CD AGE DIE
IN INFANCY.
THOSE WHO DO SURVIVE WILL HAVE A
LIFETIME OF MEDICAL
COMPLICATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO KNOWN
WAY TO PREVENT CVH BABIES BORN
WITH EDH MUST BE KEPT IN
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS AND THOSE
ARE THE MOST SEVERE CASES MUST
UNDERGO PRENATAL SURGERY OR RISK
FATAL COMPLICATIONS.
AMBER IN THE GALLERY IS THE
MOTHER OF ADDISON ROSE
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS ATTY.
SHE PASSED AWAY BECAUSE OUT
COMPLICATIONS RELATE RELATED TO
SEE DH FALLING THIRTY THREE DAYS
OF INTENSE MEDICAL BATTLE TO
SAVE HER LIFE.
WHERE IS IN CAMDEN ALSO PASSED
AWAY DUE TO COMPLICATIONS FROM
THIS HORRIBLE DISEASE?
AMBER IS DOING.
IMPORTANT WORK TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND PROVIDE COMFORT
AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT TO
FAMILIES OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE
BEEN LOST DUE THIS DISEASE.
I WANT TO THANK EVER FOR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I URGE ALL CITIZENS TO
SUPPORT RESEARCH TO ASSIST
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN AFFECTED
BY CITY H..
PLEASE HELP ME RECOGNIZING
AMBER'S HARD WORK AND THE
ONGOING FIGHT TO HELP THOSE
AFFECTED BY CAN GENERAL
DIAPHRAGMATIC HERNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG AND MISTER
KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE OUTLOOK BERMAN
AN ACCOMPLISHED SWIMMER WHO IS
WITH US IN THE GALLERY TODAY.
ALRP RECENTLY RETURNED FROM THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SPECIAL
OLYMPIC WORLD GAMES IN ABU DHABI.
ALEC ONE SILVER MEDALS IN THE
TWO HUNDRED METER FREESTYLE IN
THE FOUR BY ONE HUNDRED METER
FREESTYLE EVENT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING A VERY
WARM WELCOME TO ALEX AND HIS
FAMILY
.
AND DOCTOR QUIRK.
YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH US MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
DOCTOR QUIRK.
YES I HAVE GUESTS FROM THE
WASHINGTON HOSPITAL -- COMMUNITY
DISTRICT IN MY THAT REPRESENTS
FREMONT.
UNION CITY AND NEW YORK.
SEARCH THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND THESE ARE --
TO PEOPLE FROM THE FOUNDATION
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM ASSEMBLY
WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY THAT S. H. R. TWENTY NINE
BY DR WEBER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY HR
TWENTY NINE CLERK WILL READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER WEBER RELATIVE TO
COLLEGE BOUND DAY.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAILED IN.
THIS IS SPEAKING MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT TO YOU DAY.
HR TWENTY NINE RECOGNIZING APRIL
TWENTY SECOND AS COLLEGE BOUND
DAY.
THIS IT IS DREAM IMPORTANT DAY.
AND IT'S AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ORGANIZATION.
MOST OF YOU KNOW THAT I AM THE
DAUGHTER OF SHARECROPPERS FROM
HOPE ARKANSAS.
THE MY FATHER WAS ONLY ALLOWED
TO GO AS FAR AS A SIXTH GRADE IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION.
WHICH WAS A POOR EDUCATION EVEN
WITH THAT.
AND YET BECAUSE OF HIS
IMPORTANCE OR HIS DESIRE FOR HIS
CHILDREN.
HE INSTILLED IN US THE EXTREME
IMPORTANCE OF COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THE GOING TO COLLEGE WOULD MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN YOUR LIFE IT
WOULD CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF
YOUR LIFE AND IF YOU TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF IT.
YOU COULD GO FAR BEYOND THE
DISCRIMINATION AND THE
CHALLENGES OF BEING AFRICAN
AMERICAN IN AMERICA. FORTY YEARS
I WAS AN EDUCATOR.
AND I DID MY BEST TO TRY TO
INSPIRE YOUNG PEOPLE EVERYWHERE
TO LOOK AT EDUCATION AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THEIR
LIVES TO THE CHANGES PROJECT
THREE OF THEIR LIVES.
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
TALK ABOUT THAT TODAY THAT WE
HAVE A GROUP WITH US CALL
COLLEGE BOUND.
THIS ORGANIZATION WAS FOUNDED BY
PARENTS AND SAN DIEGO AREA.
AND NOW STRETCHES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PRIMARY INTEREST IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY STUDENTS WHO ARE
POOR.
AND STUDENTS ARE AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND OTHERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A SUPPORT
SYSTEM SO ESSENTIAL. TO HELP
THEM TO GROW TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF EDUCATION TO
DEVELOP POSITIVE SELF ESTEEM AND
TO BECOME COLLEGE STUDENTS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THEY HERE TODAY
BECAUSE A COMPARE CONCERNED
PARENTS ALLIANCE WAS STARTED
MAINLY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE A VALUE SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOW THEM TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND THAT THEY HAVE A SELF ESTEEM
TO GROW AND TO DEVELOP.
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TODAY AS WE TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT THE THE
NEED FOR COLLEGE EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND EACH YEAR WE READ THE
STATISTICS THAT CALIFORNIA WILL
BE ONE POINT ONE MILLION.
OF A COLLEGE DEGREE SHORT A
BASICALLY BEING ABLE TO HAVE
ENOUGH OF OUR STUDENTS TO RUN
THIS HIDING TECHNOLOGICAL WORLD
THAT WE LIVE IN.
SO EVERY STUDENT COUNTS AND
EVERY EFFORT TO BASICALLY CHANGE
THE LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
I AM PLEASED TODAY THOUGH HAVE
BEFORE YOU HR TWENTY NINE WHICH
DECLARES APRIL TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY NINETEEN IS COLLEGE BOUND
DAY.
AND ASK THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER DOCTOR
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
HR.
TWENTY NINE AND I'M PROUD THAT I
HAVE A CHAPTER FROM TRACY HERE
UP IN THE CHAMBER.
HERE TO ADVOCATE -- FOR COLLEGE
BOUND DAY BUT JUST AS IMPORTANT
AS ENSURING OUR STUDENTS HAVE
THE RIGHT TOOLS AND SUPPORT TO
GET INTO COLLEGE IT IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT NO WE HAVE SPOTS FOR
THEM. TO GO.
TO WE KNOW THAT OVER THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
QUALIFIED LAST YEAR TO GO TO
UNIVERSITY BUT THERE WAS NOT.
CAPACITY FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
GO.
DESPITE THE NEED FOR MORE
COLLEGE AT GRADUATES ESPECIALLY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO TURN AWAY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS AT IT WHEN
THEY WEEK WHEN THEY REQUESTED
MISSION IN OUR FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES.
COMMITTEES LIKE MINE WITH LARGE
POPULATIONS AND NO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES WITHIN FIFTY MILES
AROUND THEM OFTEN GET LEFT
BEHIND.
THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IS THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN IT AND INVEST IN OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT IS WHY I RISE TODAY
TO SUPPORT.
HR.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU DOCTOR
EGGMAN MISTER MAIENSCHEIN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY NINE
STUDENT SUCCESS REQUIRES
ENGAGEMENT IN BOTH THE SCHOOL
AND HOME ENVIRONMENTS.
THE COLLEGE BOUND PROGRAMS HAVE
A SIXTEEN YEAR SUCCESSFUL TRACK
RECORD OF HELPING TO EMPOWER
EMPOWER STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
H. R. TWENTY NINE RAISES
AWARENESS OF IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
LIKE COLLEGE BOUND ENCOURAGES
FAMILIES TO TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE
IN THEIR CHILD'S EDUCATION I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND
RESPECTFULLY RIVER WOULD REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
HE WAS MAIENSCHEIN MR BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY NINE WHICH
RECOGNIZE TODAY IS COLLEGE BOUND
DAY.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER PLAN FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA I
KNOW THE VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF
COLLEGE AND THE NEED FOR POLICY
MAKERS. TO KEEP OUR PROMISE TO
MAKE HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESSIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE. FOR FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS COLLEGE
BOUND PROGRAMS ARE CRUCIAL TO
HELP STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
NAVIGATE THE OFTEN COMPLEX AND
FRAGMENTED PATH TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
ENSURING THE STUDENTS WHO WANT
TO GO TO COLLEGE CAN.
IN PROVIDING A CLEAR WAY TO DO
SO WELL NOT ONLY LIVED UP
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES IN
COLLECTIVE COMMUNITIES BUT OUR
STATE AS A WHOLE IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS.
I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR HR TWENTY
NINE TODAY.
THERE WAS BERMAN SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION DOCTOR WEBER
YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH YES
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO THINK
CAREFULLY ABOUT THIS THIS IS NOT
THIS IS TRULY ONE OF THE MANY
RESOLUTION SO WE DEAL WITH.
AND A VERY PERFUNCTORY MANNER
BUT I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION THE CHANGES
THE LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
YEAH I THINK ABOUT MY JOURNEY
AND I HAD A YOUNG MAN ASKED ME
THIS MORNING HOW DID YOU GET TO
WHERE YOU ARE DOCTOR WEBER.
AND I HAD TO REMIND HIM OF ALL
OF THE PEOPLE ALONG THE WAY WHO
MADE A PATH FOR ME WEATHER WAS
MY CHURCH WEATHER WAS THE SOME
SOCIAL ORGANIZATION WHETHER WAS
MY COUNSELOR AT MY SCHOOL.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT MADE POSSIBLE
MEET FOR ME TO GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT A
VERY REASONABLE COST TO GET
THREE DEGREES AND ONLY -- TWELVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS THAT'S
THE VISION OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S
A DREAM OF CALIFORNIA THAT
COMBINED WITH THE SUPPORT OF A
GROUP CALLED LIKE COLLEGE BROWN.
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF YOUNG PEOPLE EACH AND EVERY
DAY AND I'M HOPING THAT AS WE
PASS THIS RESOLUTION WE NOT ONLY
ENCOURAGES YOUNG PEOPLE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
BUT WE ALSO REMIND OURSELVES OF
HOW GREAT THE INSTITUTIONS ARE
THAT WE SUPPORT IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT WE INCREASE OUR SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR HR.
TWENTY NINE AND I BELIEVE DOCTOR
WEBER IS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION CO AUTHORS.
ON HR TWENTY NINE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ADDING ON TO THE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED AND DOCTOR
WEBER BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
YES -- MEMBERS TODAY PLEASE HELP
ME WELCOME MY GUEST IN THE
GALLERY THERE'S OVER SEVENTY
COLLEGE BOUND SCHOLARS PARENTS
AND REPRESENTATIVES.
FROM CALIFORNIA MOSTLY FROM THE
SAN DIEGO BASED ORGANIZATION
INCLUDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SAN DIEGO
NEIGHBORHOOD HOUSE ASSOCIATION
THERE IN THE GALLERY OVER
SEVENTY COLLEGE BOUND STUDENTS
HAVE COME HERE TODAY.
TODAY KICKS OFF THE JOINT SPRING
WOULD TRAVEL UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA TOURING DIFFERENT
COLLEGES THEY ALL HAVE WHEN
THEIR COLLEGE BOUND SHIRTS.
AND THE ALL READY AND EAGER TO
BASICALLY GO TO UC DAVIS THIS
AFTERNOON AND BEYOND TO SEE ALL
OF THE COLLEGE CAMPUSES SO
WELCOME TO THE CAPITAL.
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR WE HAVE
SOME OUTSTANDING STUDENTS WHO
WILL BE ATTENDING COLLEGE IN THE
FALL.
RAISE YOUR HAND WE HAVE SCHEELE
INSOLVENT WHO WAS A TRACY SENIOR
WILL BE TENANTS SIERRA COLLEGE
IN THE FALL.
WE HAVE GARY GRAYSON BORIS HE
TRACY SENIOR WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BLACKBURN IN THE FALL.
WE HAVE ISSUES WITH UNIVERSITY
OF LAVERNE.
WE HAVE A STORY RIGHT WHO WAS A
POW A SENIOR WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING THE UC IRVINE IN THE
FALL.
WE HAVE MATTHEW JOHNSON WHO'S A
FIFTH GRADE SCHOLAR.
THE LOS GATOS WHO HAS UNLIMITED
POSSIBILITIES OF WHERE HE'S
GOING.
JABBAR BOND WAS EIGHT EIGHT
TENTH GRADE TRACY STUDENTS
SCHOLAR WHO IS IT KIMBALL HIGH
SCHOOL.
SCOTT MONTGOMERY FROM POWER WAYS
ELEVEN GREAT SCHOLAR WHO ATTENDS
MOUNT CARMEL HIGH SCHOOL.
AND CHARLOTTE -- CHU COOLEY WHO
IS REPRESENTING THE SAN DIEGO
NEIGHBORHOOD HOUSE ASSOCIATION
SERVING THE FAMILIES IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE SEVEN I DISTRICT
AND BEYOND.
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF COLLEGE BROWN WHO IS
A HARD WORKING SCHOLAR WHO IS A
COUNSELOR AT THE U. S. SENATE
WAS STATE OF ONE POINT AND NOW
THE EXECUTIVE.
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER OF
CONCERNED PARENT ALLIANCE AND
THE COLLEGE BOUND GROUP WHO
WORKED TIRELESSLY ON BEHALF AYE
CHILDREN DOCTOR DARLENE WILLIS
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
MEMBERS
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS WITH US
TODAY MEMBERS.
BACK ON GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS
MISTER BOND TIME GOING TO
RECOGNIZE YOU FROM MY DESK IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY IT'S MY GREAT
PLEASURE TO ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
BUFFY WICKS HONOR THE GIRLS
BASKETBALL CHAMPIONSHIP TEAMS
FROM OAKLAND HIGH SCHOOL AND
OAKLAND TECHNICAL HIGH SCHOOL.
I HAD A GREAT TIME.
WITH THIS INCREDIBLE.
GROUP ON THEIR WELL DESERVED.
THREE PARADE THROUGH THE CITY
VOCAL RECENTLY IT WAS AWESOME TO
HAVE YOU HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH US.
THESE TWO TEAMS MADE HISTORY.
BY BRINGING THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION
DIVISION THREE AND DIVISION FOR
STATE CHAMPIONSHIP TITLES HOME
WE NEED THEIR TITLES JUST TWO
DAYS.
APART THIS IS THE FIRST TIME TWO
GIRLS TEAMS FROM OAKLAND HAVE
WON A STATE CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE
SAME YEAR.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE TAX HEAD
COACH LEROY HURT AND OAKLAND
HIGHS.
HEAD COACH ORLANDO GRAY.
GREAT JOB GENTLEMEN.
THESE COACHES ALONG WITH THE
ENTIRE COACHING STAFF OF HELP
ENCOURAGE MOLDS AND GUIDE THESE
COUNTY YOUNG WOMEN TO VICTORY.
AND TO SUCCESS.
YOU HAVE MADE YOUR SCHOOL THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IN OUR OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY PROUD ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
ONLY CONGRATULATE THE WILDCATS
AND THE BULLDOGS.
ON ACHIEVING THIS GREAT SUCCESS
AND I WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN
YOUR FUTURE ENDEAVORS
CONGRADULATIONS.
THEN MS WAKE SAID LIKE RECOGNIZE
YOU AS WELL THIS WAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AND I TO WONDER WELCOME WITH
GREAT PLEASURE OAKLAND HIGH
SCHOOL IN OAKLAND TECH HIGH
SCHOOL GIRLS BASKETBALL TEAM.
ON THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
BOTH OF THESE TELL TO TEAMS WON
TITLES THIS YEAR AS A MEMBER
BONTA IT SAID AND I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE MAKING IT IS THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY THAT THE
CITY OF OAKLAND.
HAS TWO GIRLS BASKETBALL TEAMS
THAT HAVE SIMULTANEOUSLY HELD
STATE CHAMPIONSHIPS.
AND I WANT TO SAY LADIES WE KNOW
WHAT IT TAKES. TO ACHIEVE THIS
LEVEL OF SUCCESS AND DEDICATION
AND COMMITMENT WE ARE THE
SACRIFICE IT TAKES.
WE ARE VERY HONORED TO HAVE YOU
WITH US HERE TODAY WE ARE VERY
VERY PROUD OF YOU AND WISH YOU
CONTINUED SUCCESS IN YOUR
ACADEMIC.
AND ATHLETIC ACHIEVEMENTS
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WHO WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK [inaudible] TO ASSEMBLY
SECOND READING.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING CORKERY
SO MAY GO 922-407-2530 WITH A
MEMBERS 591-110-07040 THREE FIVE
HE SAID WITH A BIT AT SIX THIRTY
TO TEN SIXTY FOUR WITH A MEMBERS
FIFTEEN FORTY FOR THE MEMBERS
FIVE IT'S TO THE MINUTES. TEN
FIFTY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS LEVEL
TWENTY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS
TWELVE NINETY THREE WITH A
MEMBER CA NINETY WITH A MEMBERS
THREE SEVERAL THE MEMBERS.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY WITH A MEMBERS
THREE SEVENTY WITH A MEMBERS
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE WITH A
MEMBERS TO NINETY SIX THE MERITS
OF FORTY THREE WITH A MEMBERS
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WITH A BETTER
IT'S TRUE ONE WITH A MINUTE
SEVEN SEVEN THREE WITH THE
MINUTES AND ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING.
TO THE TOP OF THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN A. B.. FOUR ONE EIGHT BY
MISTER KALRA [inaudible]
CLOCK RATE.
SOME PEOPLE FOR EIGHTEEN BY SOME
MEMBER KALRA ACCOLADE A
PRIVILEGE.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FOR EIGHTEEN WHAT ESTABLISH
AN EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE
PROHIBITING DISCLOSURE OF
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS MAY
BETWEEN EMPLOYEE AND THEIR UNION
REPRESENTATIVE.
JUST AN EXCLUSIONARY RULE OF
EVIDENCE THAT PROTECTS CERTAIN
CLASS THE BETWEEN OCCASIONS FROM
DISCLOSURE TO OPPOSING PARTIES
AT FROM ENTRY INTO EVIDENCE IN
LEGAL PROCEEDINGS.
THE RATIONALE IS THAT ALTHOUGH
CERTAIN INFORMATION MAY BE
RELEVANT IT IS NONE THE LESS
EXCLUDED.
BECAUSE OF OVERRIDING SOCIAL
INTERESTS.
AT A TIME IN THE ME TO MOVE IN
AS EMPOWER WOMEN AND OTHERS
REPORT AND SPEAK OUT ABOUT
HARASSMENT THE WORKPLACE
ADDITIONAL CONFIDENTIAL AVENUES
REPORT THESE INCIDENCES ARE IN
GREATER NEED.
ADDITIONALLY AS WE HAVE SEEN
WORKER PROTECTIONS IN JEOPARDY
DUE TO FEDERAL POLICIES AND
COURT RULINGS WE MUST DO MORE AS
A STATE TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS.
AB FOR EIGHTEEN WOULD ADD UNION
AGENT AND REPRESENT A WORKER AS
RECOGNIZED STATUTORY EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE ALONG WITH ELEVEN
EXISTING TYSON COMMUNICATIONS
DEEMED PRIVILEGE.
BY ALLOWING EVIDENTLY PRIVILEGED
FEW WORKERS AND UNION
REPRESENTATIVES WE CAN HELP TO
ENSURE THE SAFE PRIVATE AND FULL
DISCLOSURE OF WORKPLACE CONCERNS
AND NEEDS.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS KALRA SEE NOTICE KASHER
DEBATE ON THE MEASURE.
CAR CLUB RURAL ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED TO VOTE ICE.
FORTY NINE KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY EIGHT IS AB FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR CLICK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FOUR BY SOME
MEMBERS JONES SAWYER ACCOLADE
CRIMES MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FORTY FOUR REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT THAT JUDGES MUST
SENTENCE LOW LEVEL DRUG
OFFENDERS A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
JAIL TIME AS A PROVISION OF
PROBATION. TO BE CLEAR.
SERIOUS DRUG OFFENSES THAT ARE
AN ELEGY OF THAT ARE INELIGIBLE
PROBATE PROBATION ARE NOT
INCLUDED UNDER THIS BILL.
AB FOR A FOR RETURNS POWER TO
THE COURTS BY ALLOWING THEM TO
DECIDE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
WHETHER THAT TIME SPENT IN JAIL
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE.
MANDATORY MINIMUM SENTENCES IS A
COSTLY OVERLY PUNITIVE AND
EFFECTIVE METHOD OF DETERRING
DRUG RELATED CRIMES FOR EXAMPLE
UNDER CURRENT LAW AN INDIVIDUAL
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER
SERVED TO COMMUNITY BASED
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS.
COST LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETY NINE DOLLARS FOR THEIR
TIME SPENT IN COUNTY JAIL
FURTHERMORE INCARCERATING MORE
INDIVIDUALS ONLY CONTINUES AT
PRESSURE ALREADY OVERCROWDED
FACILITIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS BILL STILL ALLOWS JUDGES TO
ORDER A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS
IN JAIL IF NECESSARY.
AB FOUR EIGHT FOUR SIMPLY
REMOVES ARBITRARY REQUIREMENTS
RITA TURNS TO SENTENCING TO
DISCRETION COURTS NEED TO
OPERATE IN THE INTEREST OF
JUSTICE.
WHERE IT WILL ALWAYS BE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
STICKERS ON ON CONVERSATIONS
AROUND HIS BILL FOR THE PURPOSE
OF TODAY'S VOTE THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DR -- FAMOUS JONES SAWYER SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES.
FORTY TWO KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWENTY
NINE PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY AB TEN THIRTEEN
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACKLEY TO SAY GOVERNMENT.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES LAST YEAR THE
STATE AUDITOR.
ISSUED A RECOMMENDATION THAT
GRANT EVALUATORS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT HAVE PRIOR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
ORGANIZATION SUBMITTING THE
GRANTS THAT THEIR EVALUATING.
THIS BILL AB TEN THIRTEEN
IMPLEMENTS THAT RECOMMENDATION
BY CREATING A FIVE YEAR
MORATORIUM ON THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS COLLEGE THIS IS A
BASIC GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL IS
WORTHY OF YOUR SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
COR GLOBAL ROLE.
RESEARCHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE IS AB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR FOUR COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
BY SHOULD BE MEMORY AS AN
ACCOLADE HEALTH FACILITIES.
MS RACE.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR IS A BILL
WHICH SIMPLY ALSO OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. TO TRACK AND
COLLECT DATA SPECIFICALLY ON
WAITING PERIODS FOR PATIENTS IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS SEEKING
TRANSFER TO PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITIES.
ENSURING TRANSFERS OCCUR AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE OF ITS IMPACT
ON THE PATIENT.
HOSPITAL STAFF AND THOSE IN NEED
OF CARE PROVIDED IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS.
AB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR PROVIDES A
LEGISLATURE HOSPITAL'S
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES AND THE
PUBLIC WITH INFORMATION THAT
WILL HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
THIRTY TWO AB ONE SEVENTY
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY BY SOME REMEMBER
GONZALEZ AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MS GONZALEZ YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AB ONE SEVENTY IS INSPIRED BY
THE STORY OF XANDER PESCARA.
A HOTEL WORKER WHO WAS WASHING
DISHES AND WAS HARASSED BY HER
SUPERVISOR.
WHEN SHE WENT ABOVE HER
SUPERVISOR TO THE HOTEL MANAGER?
HE BASICALLY TOLD HER IT DIDN'T
MATTER BECAUSE NEITHER OF THOSE
WORKERS ACTUALLY WORK FOR THE
HOTEL.
THEY WERE SUBCONTRACTED OUT
DESPITE WORKING ON THE GROUNDS
OF THE HOTEL IN DOING THE
PRIMARY WORK OF THE HOTEL.
THE TREND WE'VE SEEN ESPECIALLY
IN JANITORIAL HOTEL HOUSEKEEPING
SERVICES HAS BEEN TOWARD
OUTSOURCING WORK TO STAFFING
AGENCIES.
THESE WORKERS MAY GO TO WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY AT THE SAME
LOCATION WEARING THE SAME
UNIFORM OF THE OFFICER HOTEL
THEIR CLEAN IT REPORTING TO
MANAGERS ON SITE.
YET IF THEY'RE SEXUALLY HARASSED
THERE'S NO WAY FOR THEM TO GO.
WORKERS IN MANY CASES ARE NOT
EVEN AWARE OF THE SUB
CONTRACTING AGENCY OR WHO THEIR
ACTUAL DIRECT SUPERVISOR IS.
THESE CONTRACTING COMPANIES AND
HOTELS ARE NOT HELD RESPONSIBLE
ONE SEXUAL HARASSMENT HAPPENS ON
THEIR WATCH TO THEIR WORKERS.
WHAT IS RESULTED FROM THIS LACK
OF ACCOUNTABILITY ARE MORE
STORIES OF ABUSES IN THE
WORKPLACE PERPETRATED BY THE
SAME ACTORS OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN?
COLLEAGUES LAST YEAR WE DID A
LOT TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO
ISSUES AND WE HELPED A LOT OF
WOMEN WOMEN WHO.
YOU KNOW MIGHT HAVE A LAW DEGREE
MIGHT WORK IN HOLLYWOOD OR IN
THE HALLS OF THIS CHAMBER BUT
WHAT WE DIDN'T ADDRESS IS WOMEN
WHO WORK IN MY DISTRICT AT
HOTELS.
AND JANITORIAL COMPANIES AND
BLUE COLLAR JOBS THAT SOMETIMES
DON'T HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
RELATIONSHIP AT AT THE WORKPLACE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE IN A
TRADITIONAL ONE THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO SEEK SOME SORT OF
RECOURSE.
LAST YEAR WE BROUGHT FOR THE
BILL MANY OF YOU VOTED ON THAT
BILL AND UNFORTUNATELY WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR SO WE'RE
TRYING AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
DOES NOT LEAVE BEHIND WORKING
CLASS WOMEN AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BUILDS TENDS TO DO.
I HAVE RESPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS GONZALEZ.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS PHONE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL.
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY THREE THREE
THIRTY SIX PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN IS AB.
TWO NINETY FOUR CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINETY FOUR BY
SOME MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND OTHERS
AND ACCOLADES CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB.
TWO NINETY FOUR ATTACKS KNOWN AS
GASOLINE WHERE AN INMATE
ASSAULTS ANOTHER PERSON WITH
BODY FLUID OCCURS ALL TOO OFTEN
AT EACH OF OUR STATE
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
GAS ATTACKS ARE DANGEROUS AND
CAN EXPOSE THE VICTIM. TO A
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE AND CAUSE
PSYCHOLOGICAL DRAMA.
AB TWO NINETY FOUR CODIFIED
RECOMMENDATIONS PUT FORTH BY THE
STATE AUDITOR THAT WILL PROVIDE.
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES STAFF
WITHOUT OCCUR TRAINING TO
MITIGATE THE HARM OF THESE
ATTACKS ALONG WITH THE BORN
EMPLOYEE HEALTH INFORMATION AND
ENTITLEMENTS.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WORKING IN OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES ARE
DEDICATED IN SAFEGUARDING OUR
COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY.
THIS BILL THE SIMPLE STEP IN
ENSURING THEIR SAFETY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH
[inaudible]
FORTY PASS RETAIN.
WEIRD FILE ITEM FORTY ONE AB.
FIVE FIVE ONE CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE FIVE FIFTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER BROKE WHEN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE A FATAL VEHICULAR
ACCIDENTS.
MR BROKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FIVE FIVE ONE WILL
UPDATE CURRENT LAW REQUIRED DRUG
TESTING AFTER FATAL COLLISIONS
IN ADDITION ALCOHOL TESTING TO
BETTER REFLECT THE ACCURATE USE
OF PRESCRIPTION.
AND RECREATIONAL DRUGS
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES NEARLY
THREE THOUSAND FATAL CAR DEATHS
ANNUALLY CURRENTLY LOCAL CORNER
MEDICAL EXAMINERS ARE REQUIRED
TO TEST FOR ALCOHOL BUT NOT FOR
DRUGS AB FIVE FIVE ONE WILL HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT UNDERSTANDING
QUALIFY CAUSES BEHIND FATAL
COLLISIONS.
WILL HELP KEEP CALIFORNIA ROAD
SAFE THANK YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THING IS GROSSING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE [inaudible]
LOCAL ROLE.
VOTERS ARE LOW.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALENT ABOUT
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS. FORTY
TWO THROUGH FORTY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM.
FORTY FIVE ACR FIFTY SIX BY
MISTER RAY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER GRAY
RELATIVE TO LEARN LOS AWARENESS
MONTH.
MR GRAY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A. C. R. FIFTY SIX
DECLARES APRIL AS LIMB LOSS
AWARENESS MONTH.
THERE ARE OVER TWO MILLION
INDIVIDUALS UNITED STATES LIVING
WITH LIMB LOSS IN OVER FIVE
HUNDRED AMPUTATIONS OCCUR EVERY
DAY.
DIABETES AND PERIPHERAL VASCULAR
DISEASE ARE AMONG THE LEADING
CAUSES OF WIN LOSS WITH LIFETIME
HEALTHCARE COSTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH LIVE LOS EXCEEDING OVER A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
WHEN LOSS CAN AFFECT ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF RACE AGE GENDER?
OR SOCIAL STATUS.
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE PROSTHETIC
CARE FOR PEOPLE LIVING WITH THEM
LOS IS VITAL TO ENABLING
INDIVIDUALS TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL.
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY AND LIVE WELL.
LIKELY CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED
INSURANCE FAIRNESS LAWS FOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND
INSURANCE POLICIES THAT COVER
PROSTHETIC CARE.
WHILE TECHNOLOGY IS ADVANCING
WHEN IT COMES TO PROSTHETIC
LIMBS OBTAINING A PROSTHETIC
HAND OR LEG IS STILL A MAJOR
CHALLENGE TO THE COST AND THE
NILES FROM INSURANCE COMPANIES.
STUDIES SHOW UP 260% OF LAMB
LOSSES PREVENTABLE THROUGH
IMPROVEMENTS IN EDUCATION
NUTRITION AND HEALTH CARE.
THE NUMBER OF AMPUTATIONS WILL
DOUBLE BY TWENTY FIFTY UNLESS A
MAJOR PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
IS LAUNCHED IN KEY PREVENTION
INITIATIVES ARE PUT IN PLACE.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN
SUPPORTING ACR FIFTY SIX TO
DECLARE APRIL AS LIMB LOSS
AWARENESS MONTH TO INCREASE
AWARENESS AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THOSE AFFECTED BY LEN LOSS.
AND LIMB DIFFERENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GRAY SEE NO
ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OF THE RESOLUTION.
MR GRAY YOU WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE FIRST ROW.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MISTER GRAY BACK TO
YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
IT IS AN HONOR TODAY TO BE
JOINED IN THE GALLERY BY SEAN
HARRISON CHRIS TO MELLOW WHO ARE
DEDICATED LIMóN LOS PATIENT
ADVOCATES WHO INSPIRED THIS
RESOLUTION THAT WE JUST VOTED ON
I'M HONORED TO WORK WITH THEM
AND BRING ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE AND THANK THEM. FOR
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY SIX ACR SIXTY FOUR COREY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY BY SOME REMEMBER DEEP IN
OTHERS RELATIVE TO BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH.
MR DATE YOU MAIL BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WHO'S A SPEAKER I
RISE TO PRESENT ACR.
SIXTY WHICH WILL DECLARE THAT
APRIL AS BLACK APRIL MEMORIAL
MONTH.
SPEAKER THIS MONTH OF APRIL
FORTY FOUR YEARS AGO.
COMMUNIST TANKS WERE ROLLING
THROUGH SOUTH VIETNAM.
ONLY DAYS AWAY FROM REACHING THE
CAPITAL CITY OF SAIGON.
MY CITY OF BIRTH.
IT WAS A CHAOTIC SCENE.
EVACUATION PLANS WERE BEING MADE
BY WHAT WAS LEFT OF THE AMERICAN
PERSONNEL IN SOUTH VIETNAM AT
THAT TIME.
SOME VIETNAMESE FLEW OUT WITH
THEIR AMERICAN FRIENDS ON
MILITARY CARGO PLANES.
MANY MORE GOT A SPOT.
ON A STANDING ROOM ONLY DECK OF
A U. S. NAVY DESTROYER.
A FEW MANAGE TO CATCH A RIDE ON
THE HELICOPTERS THAT WILL
LEAVING THE US EMBASSY.
THEY WERE THE FORTUNATE ONES.
THE REST OF SOUTH VIETNAM
INCLUDING MY MOM AND DAD.
WERE LEFT BEHIND.
THE SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ON
THIS MONTH OF APRIL FORTY FOUR
YEARS AGO.
MY PARENTS AND THEIR GENERATION.
LOS EVERYTHING TO COMMUNISM.
BEFORE THIS BODY IS ACR SIXTY A
RESOLUTION THAT DECLARES THE
MONTH OF APRIL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS BLACK APRIL THE MORE
A MONTH. TO COMMEMORATE THOSE
THAT GAVE THEIR LIVES IN THE
DEFENSE OF FREEDOM.
AGAINST COMMUNISM AGAINST
TYRANNY.
AND TO REMEMBER THOSE WHO DIE IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE VIETNAM WAR.
WHETHER IT WAS IN A PRISON CAMP
OR IN THE JUNGLE OF CAMBODIA OR
SOMEWHERE IN THE PACIFIC OCEAN
ON THEIR SEARCH FOR FREEDOM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES.
I ORIGIN AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER DEEP MR.
KALRA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM WESTMINSTER -- ON
SPEAKING TO THE DETAILS OF WHY
THIS.
PARTICULAR RESOLUTION IS SO
IMPORTANT.
AND REPRESENTING THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE.
WHICH HAS THE LARGEST.
IS POPULATION OF ANY CITY
OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM I KNOW ALL
TOO WELL THE IMPACT.
OF BLACK APRIL.
ON OF MY COMMUNITY.
IN THE GENERATIONS THAT FOLLOW
WE DO KNOW THE DETAILS OF WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE HORRIFIC.
OTHER HORRIFIC DAYS WEEKS MONTHS
AND EVEN YEARS THAT FOLLOWED BY
CABLE I PERSONALLY SPOKEN. TO A
NUMBER.
OF CONSTITUENTS OF MINE.
WHO WERE IMPRISONED AND RE
EDUCATION CAMPS FOR YEARS?
FOLLOWING THE FALL OF SAIGON.
BUT WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER.
THAT IT'S NOT JUST A DAY IN TIME.
THAT WE ARE MEMORIALIZING.
BUT IT'S ALSO WHAT'S HAPPENING
EVEN TO THIS DAY WHEN YOU HAVE
THOSE THAT ARE STANDING UP FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS YOU OF BLOGGERS.
AND YOU HAVE THOSE ARE
PROTESTING INDUSTRY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
AND FOR FREEDOM.
I AND FOR HUMAN RIGHTS THAT ARE
BEING IMPRISONED BEATEN AND
KILLED TODAY IN VIETNAM.
AND SO AS WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF BLACK APRIL LET US
THINK ABOUT OUR VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES IN OUR
RESPECTIVE -- BUT DISTRICTS.
AND LET'S BE THERE TO COMFORT
THEM AND TO ASSURE THEM THAT
WE'LL DO WHATEVER WE CAN -- BUT
TO PROTECT THEIR ABILITY TO
SPEAK UP AGAINST ATROCITIES THAT
CONTINUE TO THIS DAY.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
ON ACR.
SIXTY THERE WAS KALRA MR DAILY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
I STAND ALONGSIDE THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY IN SOMBER REFLECTION
OF BLACK APRIL.
COMMEMORATING HISTORIC FALL OF
SAIGON IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE THE
REFUGEES FROM THAT SAD DAY FROM
THAT SAT ERA.
HAVE TRANSFORMED OUR COMMUNITIES
AND TAUGHT US MUCH ABOUT HISTORY
AND RESILIENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS DALY MISTER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I
HAVE THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING A
VERY PROUD.
LITTLE SAIGON DISTRICT HERE IN
OUR CAPITAL CITY.
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO AS A COUNCIL
MEMBER I WORK TO CREATE THIS
DESIGNATION I KNOW WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT BLACK APRIL AND ITS
FORTY FOURTH YEAR.
SINCE THE FALL OF SAIGON IT
COMES A LOT OF PRIDE AND
CERTAINLY A LOT OF PAIN.
CERTAINLY A LOT OF PRIDE IN IN
REPRESENTING A COMMUNITY LIKE
SAN JOSE OTHER PARTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY WHICH HAVE VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS ARE SO PROUD
OF THEIR EXPERIENCES.
AND A BRING SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND THAT WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON THAT TODAY BUT ALSO A
LOT OF PAIN REMEMBERING.
THOSE WHO -- WHO WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES DURING THAT AIR AS WELL
AND SO WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY?
FOR BRINGING UP THIS MEASURE AS
WELL AS RECOGNIZE A LITTLE
SAIGON'S THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND AS WELL VIETNAMESE.
AMERICANS IN CALIFORNIA WHO WHO
CELEBRATE RECOGNIZE -- BLACK
APRIL AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK MCCARTY MISTER VOEPEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
I RISE AS THE ONLY VIETNAM
VETERAN TO SERVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND I MAY
VERY WELL BE THE LAST.
ONE I REMIND MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
THAT IN THE VIETNAM WAR FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PLUS OF US
VIETNAM VETERANS WERE KILLED.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
KILLED AND MAIMED.
AND TODAY WE HAVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS DYING OF AGENT ORANGE
AND THE REASON I BRING THIS UP
IS NOT TO DEPRESS EVERYONE.
BUT TO LET YOU KNOW AND REMIND
YOU OF THE GREAT PRICE.
PAID. FOR OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN VIETNAM WE FOUGHT
THAT WAR TO SAVE THE COUNTRY.
AND EMBRACED ALL THE VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES THAT CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES SO I WAS GREATLY SUPPORT
ACR.
SIXTY AND GOD BLESS THE
VIETNAMESE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND UP
MEMBERS -- I I RISE SO.
AS THE PROUD [inaudible]
ADOPTIVE FATHER.
OF A BRIAN JAMES PATTERSON
[inaudible]
VIETNAMESE.
HE IS NOW FORTY SIX YEARS OLD.
AND HE SURVIVED.
THAT THAT BLACK APRIL.
WHEN SAIGON?
WAS FALLING.
PRESIDENT FORD SAID OVERSEE FIVE
AIRCRAFTS. TO TAKE THESE ORPHANS.
TO THE UNITED STATES.
A BJ WAS ONE OF THEM.
YEAH ACTUALLY SURVIVED THE ONLY
SEE FIVE A PLANE CRASH FROM THAT.
OPERATION.
MEMBERS HE IS A LIVING WITNESS.
OF THE BITTER SWEETNESS OF WHAT
WE CELEBRATE.
HERE AN HONOR HERE.
AND THAT IS.
THAT HE REMINDS ME [inaudible]
REGULARLY.
THAT JUST OVER HIS SHOULDER.
IN HIS SENSE OF TIME.
WAS.
THE POTENTIAL OF BEING IN A WAR
TORN COUNTRY.
WITH A COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT AND
NO FRIEDMAN NO OPPORTUNITY HE
REMINDS ME ALMOST EVERY COUPLE
OF WEEKS.
THAT HE IS HERE.
HE IS FREE.
HE HAS HIS OWN HOME HE HAS HIS
OWN BUSINESS.
AND HE REMINDS ME OF MY NO HE
REMINDS OTHERS.
OF WHAT IT MEANT. TO LOSE A
COUNTRY.
BUT TO GAIN ANOTHER.
THEY HAVE BEEN REMARKABLE --
PATRIOTS.
AND FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SINCE THEN.
SO LET'S NEVER EVER FORGET THAT
ALTHOUGH IT WAS A BLACK DAY.
IN THE HISTORY.
OF THE VIETNAM PEOPLE AS A
NATION.
MANY HAVE FOUND THE BRIGHTNESS
AND THE HOPE.
OF WHAT IT MEANS TO BE.
AN AMERICAN.
AND SO WE REMIND OURSELVES.
WITH THIS RESOLUTION.
OF THE BITTERNESS.
BUT I RISE ALSO. TO REMIND
MYSELF AGAIN AND THIS
REPRESENTATIVE.
BODY OF THE SWEETNESS.
OF HAVING THESE PEOPLE IN OUR
MIDST.
AND SHARON AND I FOR HAVING ONE
OF THE MEN ARE FAMILY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THERE WAS PATTERSON.
MISTER KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR.
AND THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WESTMINISTER FOR BRINGING THOSE --
A IMPORTANT ACR FOR A BLACK
APRIL TO COMMEMORATE A VERY DARK
TIME IN HISTORY. FOR MANY
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES.
A DEAD THAT DAY IS STILL VOTE
VERY PAINFUL FOR MANY OLDER
GENERATION VENUE MEANS WHO
WOULDN'T IN THE STATE
DESTRUCTION OFF TO WAR.
AND THE LOSS OF THEIR COUNTRY.
JUST LIKE MANY REFUGEES FROM THE
PAST AND TODAY.
THOSE WHO FLED VIETNAM ED AFTER
ON OR AFTER APRIL THIRTIETH.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE DID NOT
HAVE A CHOICE.
THEY LOVE TO FIND A BETTER LIFE.
AND FREEDOM FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
LUCKY FOR US MANY OF THEM CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME.
AND THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY IN
MY DISTRICT HAS CONTRIBUTED SO
MUCH TO THE LOCAL CULTURAL.
CALL ECONOMIC AND CHARACTERS.
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO THANK ALL THE VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES FOR DEAR.
POSITIVE POSITIVE CONTRIBUTION.
M. FOR REMINDING US TO HAVE
FREEDOM COM AT THE PRICE AND
THAT WE SHOULD VALUE.
OUR FRIEDMAN AND EXPAND OR
SUPPORT TO REFUGEES WAR WHY.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SAYING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MR DEEP YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
MISTER SPEAKER I ASK THAT THE
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHOR AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
IS THE FIRST ROLL THE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON
TO THE RESOLUTION -- THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS CLUB.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR A GUEST
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THIS
RESOLUTION.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS
I NOTED EARLIER TEN YEARS AGO
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE FOUND THAT
OUR LITTLE SAIGON DISTRICT.
WITH THE INSPIRATION OF MY
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALLING
ARE SOMETHING EVER CALLING FROM
ORANGE COUNTY VAN TRANH.
HE KINDA SLOWED AS THE ROAD MAP
HOW WE COULD DO THAT UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SO WITH US TODAY ARE
pKEVIN KNEW IN.
HIS ACTED WITH THE SACRAMENTO
GREATER VIETNAMESE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND NEO TRêN.
THEY'RE BOTH PART OF THE
LEADERSHIP COMMITTEE OF LITTLE
SAIGON SACRAMENTO WHO TEN YEARS
AGO HELP US CREATE THIS DISTRICT
ONE TO WELCOME THEM TO OUR STATE
CAPITOL THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE WILL HAVE ORDER IN
THE CHAMBER.
WE WILL HAVE ORDER IN THE
GALLERY
.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE REFRAIN FROM
OUTBURSTS.
FROM THE GALLERY OF ANY KIND
THANK YOU.
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN PASSED
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM. FORTY EIGHT IS A BE
[inaudible]
SEVEN NINETY FIVE CARILLO.
SOME PEOPLE SEVEN NINETY FIVE BY
SOME REMEMBER IRWIN ACRYLATE THE
CEMETERIES MS ARE WHEN YOU MAIL.
MISTER SPEAKER EIGHTY SEVEN NINE
FIVE HELPS ENSURE THE LONG TERM
SOLVENCY OF CEMETERY ENDOWMENT
CARE TRUST FUNDS SO THAT ONGOING
CARE AND MAINTENANCE TO NOT
BECOME THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
TAXPAYERS THIS BILL SETS LIMITS
ON TRUSTEE COMPENSATION TO ALLOW
FOR APPROPRIATE MANAGEMENT OF
TRUST ASSETS.
PLACES CHECKS ON EXCESSIVE FEES
AND LIMITS THE ABILITY OF
PRIVATE CREDITORS TO SEIZE TRUST
FUND.
ASSETS AB SEVEN NINE THREE HAS
NO OPPOSITION AS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLARK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER SERVER.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE IS AB SIX THIRTY ONE
CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE SIX THIRTY ONE BY
SOME WE WERE MCCARTY ANOTHER
SNACK LATER PUBLIC TRANSIT.
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
A MEASURE LATE TO OUR LOCAL
TRANSIT DISTRICTS ACT MINORITY
SENSUALLY A DISTRICT BILL.
THAT MODERNIZE IS THERE VOTE
THRESHOLDS FOR A CITY LEAVING
THE TRANSIT DISTRICT -- HAS NO.
OPPOSITION ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THERE IS A GUARDING SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
ABOUT AYE SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FIFTY AND FIFTY ONE PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM.
FIFTY TWO AB SIXTY FIVE COVERAGE.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS ANOTHER
SNACK LATER COASTAL PROTECTION.
THIS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB SIXTY FIVE THIS
BILL WILL INVEST IN GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE CALIFORNIA
COAST IN ORDER TO COMBAT SEA
LEVEL RISE.
THE CALIFORNIA COAST IS EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILES OF
BREATHTAKING BEAUTY HOME TO
ALMOST 70% OF CALIFORNIANS.
AND A CRITICAL DRIVER OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
BUT ALL OF THIS IS AT RISK FROM
SEA LEVEL RISE SEE LEVELS ARE
PROJECTED TO RISE BY FIVE FEET
BY THE END OF THE CENTURY.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE DIRECTLY AT RISK
UNLESS WE ACT NOW.
AND TO COMBAT SEA LEVEL RISE
NATURE ITSELF IS ITS BEST
DEFENSE SOME EXAMPLES OF NATURAL
OR GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE LEVEL
RISE INCLUDE DUNES WHICH PRODUCE
FLOODING AND REPLENISH.
BEACHES KELP AND SEA GRASS WHICH
REDUCE WEIGHT IMPACT AND MARCHES
WHICH REDUCE FLOODING AND
EROSION.
NATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ACCORDING TO THE EPA ACTUALLY
COSTS LESS THAN CONVENTIONAL
GRAY INFRASTRUCTURE MAKING THIS
A COST EFFECTIVE AND RESILIENT
APPROACH TO COASTAL ADAPTATION.
AS PART OF THE PARK BOND THAT
VOTERS APPROVED IN JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN FUNDING IS AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST COASTAL COMMUNITIES WITH
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS SEALABLE
RISE.
THIS BILL WILL UTILIZE THIS
FUNDING TO INVEST IN GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE PROVEN TO WORK.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST FOR YOUR I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU IS PETRIE-NORRIS
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM [inaudible]
CLICK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM [inaudible]
FIFTY THREE IS AB. FOR SIXTY TWO
BY MYSTERON RE GUESS CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY TWO BY
SOME MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN
ACCOLADE PUBLIC RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS THIS RODRIGUEZ.
THANK MANAGEMENT MAPS SPEAKER
MEMBERS I WANT TO PRESS A RISE
TO PRESENT A BEFORE.
SIXTY TWO THIS BILL SIMPLY MAKES
A MINOR CHANGE TO THE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT LAW AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT LAW
ADMINISTERED BY.
CASTERS AND CALPERS RESPECTFULLY.
ARE FRANKLY US RIVAL.
THANK YOU MS RODRIGUEZ SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR GLOBAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF OUT
[inaudible]
THERE ARE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
FIFTY FOUR IS A BEAST EIGHT
THIRTY THREE BY MR LACKEY
CORKERY.
FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR AB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY THREE
BY SOME REMEMBER LACKEY AN
ACCOLADE CANNABIS.
MR LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PROUD REPRESENT AB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE WHICH URGES THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROLLED
REVISES MINIMUM SAFETY STANDARDS
FOR DISTRIBUTORS.
WHEN CARRYING LARGE SUMS OF
MONEY OR CANNABIS PRODUCTS?
CURRENTLY THERE ARE A FEW A
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS FOR CANNABIS
DISTRIBUTORS FOR EXAMPLE TRANSIT
VEHICLES CANNOT BE VISIBLE OR
IDENTIFIABLE FROM OUTSIDE.
SEE THIS IS VERY EXCITING TO
EVERYBODY.
EACH TRENDS VEHICLE MOST HAVE
ALARM SYSTEM WHEN A TRANS A
VEHICLE IS LEFT UNATTENDED IT
ALSO HAS TO BE LOCKED AND
SECURED HOWEVER.
THERE BEEN SEVERAL INSTANCES
WHERE DISTRIBUTORS HAVE BEEN
ROBBED THREATENED AND EVEN
BEATEN.
AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY URGING THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO CORPORATE
ADDITIONAL.
SECURITY MEASURES SUCH AS THE
REST SYSTEMS OR HOLD UP ALARM
SHOULDER DISTRIBUTORS ARE SAFE.
AND THE PRODUCTS DO NOT FALL
INTO THE WRONG HANDS ASK YOUR
RIVAL.
AMOS LACKEY SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
OR CALL THE ROLL.
IT IS OUR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF
WHAT I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS.
FIFTY FIVE THROUGH FIFTY SEVEN
PASS AND RETAIN WORD FILE ITEM.
FIFTY EIGHT ACR SIXTY SEVEN
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO RELATIVE TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT [inaudible]
IS RUBIO.
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENTE SIERRA SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH PROCLAIMS APRIL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AS SEXUAL
ASSAULT AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND RECOGNIZE APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH TWENTY NINETEEN AS THEM
DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO START OUT BY
EXPLAINING THE HISTORY OF DENIM
DAY.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
ITALIAN SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED
THE CONVICTION OF A MAN WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WOMAN AFTER
THE COURT DETERMINED.
THAT BECAUSE THE VICTIM WERE
VERY VERY TIGHT JEANS SHE HAD TO
HELP HIM REMOVE THEM.
AND BY REMOVING THE JEANS IT WAS
NO LONGER RAPE BY CONTRACT
CONSENSUAL SEX.
RIGHTFULLY ENRAGED BY THE COURT
DECISION WITHIN A MATTER OF
HOURS THE WOMEN IN THE ITALIAN
PARLIAMENT.
LAUNCHED INTO MEDIA ACTION AND
PROTESTED.
BY WEARING JEANS TO WORK.
NATIONS IN STATES THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD HAVE FOLLOWED THE LEAD OF
THE ITALIAN PARLIAMENT BY
DESIGNATING THEIR OWN DENIM DAY
TO RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT.
PEOPLE OF ALL GENDERS AND AGES
ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND IT IS ESTIMATED THAT NEARLY
ONE IN TWO WOMEN AND ONE IN FIVE
MEN EXPERIENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
OTHER THAN READ THROUGH THEIR
LIFETIME.
IN TWENTY TWELVE AN ESTIMATED
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WERE THE VICTIMS OF SOME FORM OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
AND WHEN FACTORING THAT SOME
VICTIMS WERE ASSAULTED
REPEATEDLY DURING THE YEAR THE
TOTAL INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
IN THE STATE EXCEEDED ONE POINT
ONE MILLION. EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT FOUND THAT THE
TANGIBLE COST OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PREVENTION
INVESTIGATION SANCTIONING
TREATMENT AND VICTIM SERVICES
TOTAL OVER NINE BILLION DOLLARS.
ONE FULL ATTITUDES ABOUT RAPE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLOW THESE
CRIMES TO PERSIST AND ALLOW
SURVIVORS TO BE RE VICTIMIZED.
THROUGH VICTIM BLAMING ATTITUDES
AND SOMETIMES UNRESPONSIVE
GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS.
I ENCOURAGE OUR MAIL ALLIES TO
FOLLOW OUR LEAD AND STAND UP TO
THIS HORRIFIC BEHAVIOR WHENEVER
POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS RUBIO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MS RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION YES
PLEASE.
QUIRK LOW FOR THE ROLE FOR
DOCTORS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS [inaudible]
CO AUTHORS.
ON A C. R. [inaudible]
SIXTY SEVEN CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
BACK ON THE FILE WE YOU HAVE.
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE AND SIXTY WE ARE FILE ITEM.
SIXTY ONE AB TWELVE THIRTY FOUR
BY MISTER PATTERSON CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER PASSING
ANOTHER'S AN ATHLETE A
STANDARDIZED TEST.
MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ONE TWO THREE FOUR SIX TO
AMEND.
OUTDATED LAWS GOVERNING
STANDARDIZED TESTING IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT AC T. MAY
OFFER A SEVENTH TESTS TO
STUDENTS IN JULY.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NEARLY ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
WENT OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA SO
THEY COULD TAKE THE ACT IN JULY
ALL OTHER STATES EXCEPT
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK OFFER A
JULY TEST DATE.
THE CURRENT TEST DEVELOPMENT
CYCLE TO PRODUCE THE REQUIRED
TEST FORMS WE'LL TAKE A CT AS
LONG AS TWO AND A HALF YEARS --
YET IF THIS BILL DOES BECOME LAW
THEY CAN'T START OFFERING THE
ADDITIONAL SUMMER TEST TO
STUDENTS NEXT YEAR AB ONE TWO
THREE FOUR PASSED OUT OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. TWELVE TO NOTHING HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THERE WAS PATTERSON SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS SIXTY TWO THROUGH
SIXTY FOUR PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SIXTY FIVE IS AB THREE
NINETY FOUR CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE THREE NINETY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER OBERNOLTE ANOTHER
SNACK RELATE TO ONE OF OUR ONE
OF QUALITY.
MR OF AN AUSSIE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
I THINK EVERYONE IN THIS CHAMBER
REMEMBERS THE DEVASTATING
CAMPFIRE FROM NOVEMBER LAST YEAR
IT WAS THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND
THE DEADLIEST WILDFIRE
CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY.
IT WAS ALSO THE NATION'S MOST
COSTLY DISASTER IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALONG WITH
MANY OF YOU I TOOK A TOUR OF THE
DEVASTATED TOWN OF PARADISE IN
JANUARY.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLY EMOTIONAL
EXPERIENCE FOR ME TO SEE.
THE DEVASTATION IN THAT
COMMUNITY WITH WHOLE
SUBDIVISIONS SUPERMARKETS.
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
BUT THE MOST AFFECTING PIECE OF
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD THAT DAY
WAS FROM THE FIRST RESPONDERS
WHO WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVACUATING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
TOWN OF PARADISE.
PARADISE HAS FOR EGRESS ROUTES
THE END YET THE SPREAD OF THE
FIRE WAS SO RAPID.
THAT OVER 50% OF THE STRUCTURES
THAT BURNED IN THAT FIRE WERE
IGNITED WITHIN FOUR HOURS TO THE
IGNITION OF THE FIRE.
SO THERE WAS NO TIME TO GET
PEOPLE OUT OF THE TOWN OF
PARADISE DESPITE THOSE FOR YOU
GROSS ROUTES IN FACT THE FLAMES
ADVANCED SO RAPIDLY.
THAT PEOPLE ABANDONED THEIR
VEHICLES AND ALL FOUR OF THOSE
ROUTES WERE COMPLETELY CLOGGED
WE HEARD SURVIVORS TALK ABOUT
SHELTERING IN THE MIDDLE OF
MEADOWS.
SHELTERING IN THEIR VEHICLES IN
THE MIDDLE OF INTERSECTIONS
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE BIGGEST
STRETCH OF ON VEGETATED GROUND
THAT THEY COULD FIND AND
THANKFULLY FOR MOST OF THEM OF
THAT STRATEGY WORKED.
BUT WE WILL NOT BE SO LUCKY IN
THE FUTURE.
THIS BILL ONLY BE THREE NINETY
FOUR CREATES THE VERILY VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED EXEMPTION TO
SEE C<c.cyan>. FOR THE PURPOSES OF</c>
CONSTRUCTION NEW EGRESS ROUTES
OUT OF FIRE PRONE COMMUNITIES
THAT LACK THEM.
I LIVE IN A COMMUNITY WITH ONLY
THREE EGRESS ROUTES AND MANY
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ONLY TWO OR SOMETIMES EVEN.
ONE COLLEAGUES THIS BILL STRIKES
AN APPROPRIATE COMPROMISE
BETWEEN THE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT ON THE ONE HAND.
AND THE NEED TO CONSTRUCT NEW
EGRESS ROUTES OUT OF FIRE PRONE
COMMUNITIES ON THE OTHER I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS ROBIN ALL THE
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL.
THE SUN IS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF
THE CEREMONY [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
FILE ITEMS SIXTY SIX AND SIXTY
SEVEN PASSED RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT AB
FOR NINETY FOUR CORKERY?
SOME PEOPLE FOR NINETY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER BERMAN ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES AND
THE CLEARLY YEARS EITHER OF THE
TECH FAQ IMMEDIATELY.
MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB FOR NINETY FOUR
WOULD MAXIMIZE CAL FRESH FOOD
BENEFITS FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS BY SIMPLIFYING THE
VERIFICATION OF THEIR HOUSING
EXPENSES.
THIS BILL WILL BE ESPECIALLY
BENEFICIAL TO THE ESTIMATED FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW INCOME
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO WILL BE NEWLY
ELIGIBLE FOR CALIFORNIA FACT OF
JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OR CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF BUT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE PASS RETAIN
WHERE FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN
ACCOLADES SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINATIONS.
MR BERMAN EMAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
SIX TO IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY
EFFICIENCY AND QUALITY OF
MEDICAL EVIDENCE YEAR
EXAMINATIONS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS.
AFTER AND DURING A SEXUAL
ASSAULT THOMAS ACCESS TO TRAUMA
INFORMED IN EVIDENCE BASED CARE
CAN PREVENT ADVERSE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND ALLOW FOR THE
PROPER COLLECTION OF EVIDENCE.
THIS BILL RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DAVIS BERMAN SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
OUR GLOBAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF ROSARIO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS OUT OF
THE CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE PASS RETAIN.
ME.
WORD FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE WE'RE
GOING TO PASS RETAIN.
ALSO PASSING A RETAINING ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY TWO AND SEVENTY
THREE WHERE IT FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR A. B. NINE NINETY EIGHT
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE NINE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND I PLAY THE STATE
HIGHWAYS MS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB.
NINE NINE EIGHT ADD STATE
HIGHWAY ONE TWENTY EIGHT TO THE
LIST OF HIGHWAYS ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SCENIC HIGHWAY
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL IS THE FIRST STEP IN
THE PROCESS TO DESIGNATE HIGHWAY
AS SCENIC.
STATE ROUTE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
RUNS FROM THE COAST IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY ONE THROUGH FOUR COUNTIES
AND INS IN MY HOMETOWN OF
WINTERS CALIFORNIA IN YOLO
COUNTY.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT INTEREST
IN THE REGION TO PURSUE THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVITALIZE
TOURISM IN AN AREA THAT HAS BEEN
DEVASTATED BY RECENT WILDFIRES
AND NATURAL DISASTERS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE IS AIR CURRY SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
PHONE IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
THE WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AND SEVENTY
SIX PASS RETAIN FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY SEVEN IS AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT QUIRK REYES.
SOME A BILL LEVIN SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SOME MEMORABLE QUIRK ACCOLADE
A PUBLIC HEALTH.
DOCTOR QUIRK EMAIL.
THANK YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT REQUIRES
THE PROBIOTIC MANUFACTURERS. TO
LABEL THEIR PRODUCTS WITH THE
GENUS SPECIES AND STRAIN OF
MICROORGANISMS IN DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS.
AS WELL AS A TOTAL ESTIMATED
COUNT OF LIFE MORE.
LIVE MICRO ORGANISMS.
CURRENT FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES
MANUFACTURERS TO LISTING
QUANTIFY AGREEMENTS AND DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS. FOR TRADITIONAL
DIETARY INGREDIENTS LIKE CALCIUM
LISTING THE COMMON NAME AND
QUALIFYING BY WEIGHT MAKES
INTUITIVE SENSE. FOR LIVE
MICROORGANISMS IS IMPORTANT TO
USE THE METRIC THAT ACTUALLY
REFLECTS HOW MANY ALIVE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK BE ARRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS NOT A DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WELL.
THOSE ARE ALL T<c.cyan> ABOUT AYE</c>
SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY AND SEVENTY
NINE PASS.
AND RETAIN.
WE ARE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDARS
SEEING AND HEARING.
NINE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
EXECUTOR.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE
NACH LATENESS OF ELECTIONS.
CLICK COOPER THE WRONG -- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ERA VOTE THIS IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS OF A
RESERVE OF CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CIRCLE READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO MY
GOAL OF FORTY TWO I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SO WE WILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
SIXTEEN THIRTY SEVEN I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SUM AGO EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO AND ASSEMBLY.
BILL EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN I SEVENTY
THREE NO
[inaudible]
ZERO MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
IN WITHDRAWAL A. B. FIFTEEN TEN
REYES FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
IN ORDER TO BUILD A SECOND
READING FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED GERMAN TO MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR GERMAN TO MEMORY GIVER
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS A READ A
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
IOLA AM WILLIAMS WAS BORN ON
FEBRUARY SECOND.
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX IN
HATTIESBURG MISSISSIPPI.
SHE MARRIED GEORGE WILLIAMS A U.
S. AIR FOR AIRFORCE MASTER
SERGEANT.
AND AFTER EXTENSIVE TRAVEL AS A
MILITARY FAMILY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THE WILLIAM SETTLED IN
SAN JOSE.
WHERE MRS WILLIAMS BECAME THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN
ELECTED TO THE FRANK YOU MAKE
HIM THE SCHOOL BOARD?
IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
TWENTY SEVEN WILLIAMS BECAME
ACTIVE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AND NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS AND CHAIRED
ONE OF SIX STANDING COMMITTEES.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE SCHOOL
BOARD.
ON JANUARY FOURTH.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE MRS IOLO
WILLIAMS AGAIN RESHAPED HISTORY
AS THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
ELECTED TO THE SAN JOSE CITY
COUNCIL.
WILLIAMS HELD THIS POSE FOR
TWELVE YEARS WHICH INCLUDED TWO
TERMS AS A VICE MAYOR OF ONE OF
THE NATION'S LARGEST CITIES.
IN ADDITION WILLIAMS ALONG WITH
MAYOR JANET GRAY HAZE AND SIX
OTHER.
THE FEMALE COLLEAGUES AS CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS MADE NATIONAL
HISTORY WHEN EIGHT OF ELEVEN
COUNCIL PERSONS WERE FEMALE.
DURING THIS TIME THESE WOMEN
INCLUDING.
I THE WILLIAMS PUT SAN JOSE ON
THE MAP AS THE FEMINIST CAPITAL
OF AMERICA BECAUSE AT THAT TIME.
NO OTHER CITY OR COUNTY IN THE
NATION HAD SUCH A HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN REPRESENTING
THEIR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
PEACEFULLY AFTER A LONG JOURNEY
A PUBLIC SERVICE I ALTHOUGH
WILLIAMS PASSED AWAY ON APRIL
FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HELLO
BILLIONS LUBBOCK SAN JOSE AND
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT SAN JOSE
LOVED.
I ALTHOUGH WILLIAMS AND SHE WILL
BE MISSED.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
CHURNING IN MEMORY OF VIOLA AND
WILLIAMS.
THANK YOU MISS KALRA MR DAILY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I STAND IN A GERMAN.
OF MEMORY OF THE LATE FRANK
PASSED QUALITY BARBERO.
FRANK WAS BORN IN DETROIT
MICHIGAN IN.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE HE WAS A
RESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY FOR
SIXTY FOUR YEARS.
FOLLOWING.
HE SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE AND WAS
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE TOP ONE
HUNDRED SUPER LAWYERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
FRANK GREW UP IN THE CITY A
GARDEN GROVE AND GRADUATED FROM
GARDEN GROVE HIGH SCHOOL.
HE ATTENDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS A
SCHOLARSHIP STUDENT.
ALL THE WHILE WORKING AS A
JUNGLE CRUISE SKIPPER AT
DISNEYLAND.
HE ALSO EARNED HIS LAW DEGREE
FROM USC.
MR BARBERO EMBODIED MANY OF THE
QUALITIES OF A LEADER HE WAS
COMPASSIONATE CHARISMATIC.
AND ALWAYS LOYAL TO HIS FRIENDS.
FRANK IS SURVIVED BY HIS TWO
SONS BRETT AND CASEY.
HE LEAVES BEHIND A REMARKABLE
LEGACY IN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND CALIFORNIA.
FIGHT ON FRANK WE WILL MISS YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER DAILY THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSIONS SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTY FOURTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS A NINE AM ALL
OF THE ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR OBERNOLTE MOVES MISS WAKE
SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED
[inaudible]
THE CHANGE [inaudible] FOR
PATTERSON.
FILE TWENTY SEVEN AB.
FOUR ONE EIGHT I TO KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE PATTERSON SOME AGO
FOR EIGHTEEN I TO KNOW